COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
NOW COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHER IN SEND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING UIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
TO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW THAT AND WE
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS.
877-336-4437 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT
FOUR TWO EIGHT FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR WHO WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN UP YOUR LINE
AND AT THE TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL. YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR SO THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME. YOU WILL BE ON MUTED
ANNUAL. YOU ARE READY TO READ.
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE. THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WOULD LIKE
TO MAINTAIN DECORUM TODAY
DURING THE HEARING ****
CUSTOMARY AND- ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE ROOM. REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
COMPS CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS. IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT TO ALL
INTERESTS SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES COULD BE HEARD WELCOME
EVERYBODY OUR HEARING TODAY IS
BIFURCATED INTO SECTIONS. THE
FIRST IS A FOCUS ON ELECTRICITY
RELIABILITY. AND THE SECOND
PORTION OF THE REQUIRED ANNUAL
UPDATES FROM BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. AND THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE. AND I
BELIEVE WE'RE READY TO BEGIN
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN TWENTY
YEARS CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED
ROTATING ELECTRICITY OUTAGES
WHEN THE ELECTRIC GRID OPERATOR
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR. FORCED
ELECTRIC ELECTRICITY OUTAGES IN
ORDER TO BALANCE I'M IN ORDER
TO BALANCE THE LECTURE CITY
SUPPLY AND DEMAND ON FRIDAY
AUGUST FOURTEENTH AND SATURDAY
AUGUST FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY. THE OUTAGES OCCURRED IN
THE MEN'S METS THE BUT EXTREME
HEAT WAVE AFFECTING MUCH OF THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES THE
AUGUST FOURTEENTH ROTOR
ROTATING OUTAGES CAUGHT MANY BY
SURPRISE AND RESULTED IN THE
LOSS F POWER DURING THE
EVENING HOURS TO NEARLY FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CUSTOMERS
WITHIN CRISIS FOOTPRINT. FOR
THE DURATION OF FIFTEEN MINUTES
TO NEARLY TWO AND A HALF HOURS
DEPENDING ON THE UTILITY
SERVICE TERRITORY. THE AUGUST
FIFTEENTH ROTATING UTAGES
AFFECTED FEWER CUSTOMERS FOR
SHORT SHORTER DURATION
SPECIFICALLY. THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND CUSTOMERS
EXPERIENCE ROTATING OUTAGES
RANGING BETWEEN EIGHT MINUTES
IN THE SDG AND E. CERTAIN
UTILITY SERVICE TERRITORY. TO
ONE AND A HALF HOURS IN THE
PG&E UTILITY SERVICE TERRITORY
WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
CUSTOMERS IN BETWEEN THESE
EVENTS OCCURRED AT A TIME WHEN
TEMPERATURES WERE SOARING. AND
CALIFORNIANS WERE RELYING ON
ELECTRICITY TO BOTH OPERATE AIR
CONDITIONING IN ORDER TO KEEP
COOL AND TO MAINTAIN
CONNECTIVITY HAS MANY WERE
WORKING OR STAYING HOME IN
ORDER TO REDUCE YOUR RISK OF
INFECTIONS FROM THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AS WE ALL CAN
ATTEST AND AS A PANDEMIC HAS
UNDERSCORED. ELECTRICITY IS AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE TO SUPPORT
MODERN LIFE THEREFORE IN ANY
BIG UNEXPECTED AND EVEN
EXPECTED LOSS OF POWER CAN POSE
INCONVENIENCES CHALLENGES AND
POTENTIAL HARM SOME CONTEXT FOR
THESE OUTAGES IF WE CAN PROVIDE
SOME THE ROTATING OUTAGES IN
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY WERE
VASTLY SHORTER DURATION THAN
SOME OF THE RECENT EXPERIENCES
WITH PRO ACTIVE POWER SHUT OFF
USED BY UTILITIES TO REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK FROM UTILITY
EQUIPMENT OR DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM OUTAGES WHICH IN MANY
CASES CAN BE HOURS EVEN DAYS
FOR FULL RESTORATION OF
SERVICE. NONETHELESS THE
ROTATING OUTAGES EXPERIENCED IN
AUGUST ALONG WITH SUBSEQUENT
POTENTIAL THREATS OF ROTATING
OUTAGES SINCE AUGUST RAISES
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ABILITY OF
THE ELECTRIC GRID OPERATOR AND
STATE AGENCIES TO NEED TO
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS WHICH MAY
BECOME MORE FREQUENT AND
INTENSE CLIMATE CHANGE THE
PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING IS
TO LEARN WHAT ACTIONS ARE BEING
TAKEN BY THE CHI'S SO THE CPUC
AT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION IN ORDER TO MITIGATE
AGAINST THE POTENTIAL FOR
FUTURE WIDESPREAD ROTATING
OUTAGES WE HOPE TO SPECIFICALLY
HERE HOW THESE ENTITIES ARE
WORKING TO BETTER PREPARE THE
ELECTRIC GRID FOR EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS ESPECIALLY TO ENSURE
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE DURING
THE NEXT PEAK LOAD. THE TIME
WHEN ELECTRICITY DEMAND IS
STILL HIGH BUT VARIABLE
RESOURCES SUCH AS SOLAR AND
WIND ARE NOT AVAILABLE. THANK
YOU. TO EVERYONE WHO IS
PARTICIPATING TODAY ALSO SHOWED
UP TO THE VICE CHAIR THANK YOU.
FOR PARTICIPATING IN THIS-
HEARING TODAY. I'D LIKE TO GO
STRAIGHT- DIRECTLY TO THE
PRESENTERS I SHOULD NOTE THAT
ALL OF THE PRISONERS ARE
PARTICIPATING. REMOTELY WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THE CPUC PRESIDENT
MARIBEL BANTER WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU- MADAM PRESIDENT TO
OUR HEARING TODAY AND THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK YOU'RE DOING FOR
THE- RESIDENTS OF THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR WAY SO AND VICE
CHAIR DOLLY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. FIRST I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR INVITING ME AND
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
AND THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR SHOULD BE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. ONE OF THE
LESSONS FROM LAST AUGUST IT IS
THAT IT IS CRITICAL WE ENHANCE
TRANSPARENCY AND BETTER INFORM
THE PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDERS.
REGARDING THE POTENTIAL
CHALLENGES WE SEE AHEAD OF US
THIS AND IN SEVERAL SUBSEQUENT
SUMMERS. THE VARIOUS PUBLIC
MEETINGS HOSTED BY OUR-
RESPECTIVE INSTITUTIONS OVER
THE LAST YEAR INCLUDING. THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS
SERVED TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON THE
IMPORTANT LESSON AND
RESPONSIBILITY. LAST YEAR OUR
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN MOVING
ALMOST NONSTOP TO IMPLEMENT
MANY OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS OF
LAST SUMMER'S EVENTS. WE WROTE
THE GOVERNOR THEN THAT WE QUOTE
SHARED IN THE RESPONSIBILITY
PROVIDE MANY CALIFORNIANS
UNNECESSARILY INDOORS. AND WE
COMMITTED OURSELVES TO
IMPROVING THE STATE'S POSITION
STAND A SIMILAR EXTREME WEATHER
EVENT IN THE FUTURE AND TO
PROTECT THE SAFETY OF THOSE WE
SERVE. MEETING THIS COMMITMENT
AS REQUIRED AN ENHANCED LEVEL
OF COORDINATION AND PROBLEM
SOLVING AND I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SINCERE GRATITUDE.
FOR THE COLLABORATION SUPPORT
THE LEADERSHIP AND STAFF OF OUR
RESPECTIVE ORGANIZATIONS. HAVE
DEMONSTRATED IN SOME DO GOING
THE SUMMER WE JUST PLAN INPUT
TO BETTER REFLECT THE CHANGING
CLIMATE REPORTER CUMAN OF
ADDITIONAL SO RESOURCES LIKE
STORAGE AND CREATED INNOVATIVE
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS TO
HELP ENSURE WE'RE SUPPORTING
CUSTOMERS. DURING THE CRITICAL
HOURS OF THE DAY WHEN THE SUN
IS SETTING BUT ENERGY USE
REMAINS HIGH AND WE HAVE MADE
CHANGES TO OUR ENERGY MARKET
RULES AS WELL. ALL OF THIS HAS
BEEN DONE PROPERLY AND WITH
GREAT SENSITIVITY TO LIMITING
ANY NEGATIVE ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THE CITY
IS PART WE HAVE FACILITATED THE
DIRECTOR PROCUREMENT OF
CAPACITY AND ESTABLISHED-
ESTABLISHMENT OF NEW PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE INCREASED DEMAND. AND
SUPPLY SIDE RESOURCES FOR THIS
SUMMER AND NEXT. SPECIFICALLY
WE ORDERED I- USED TO BE CURING
MINIMUM OF AN ADDITIONAL ONE
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF RESOURCES
REPRESENTING AN EFFECTIVE
INCREASE OF THE PLANNING
RESERVE MARGIN. FROM. 15% TO
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE. WE
ESTABLISHED A PILOT EMERGENCY
LOAD REDUCTION PROGRAM DESIGNED
TO COMPENSATE LARGE CUSTOMERS
FOR VOLUNTARILY REDUCING DEMAND
WHEN CALLED UPON BY CALAIS SO
IN THE EVENT OF A GRID. THE
MARGIN SEE WE ALSO ORDERED
MODIFICATIONS TO EXISTING
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS TO
EXPAND OR JUST A PATIENT AND
INCREASED ENROLLMENT TO ATTRACT
NEW CUSTOMERS AND WE RE
LAUNCHED A NEW STATEWIDE FLEX
ALERT PROGRAM EDUCATE CONSUMERS
ABOUT THE NEED TO CONSIDER WHEN
ENERGY DEMAND IS HIGH. FOR THIS
EASY HAS BUILT UPON ANALYSIS
AND DEVELOP NEW ANALYTICAL
PRODUCTS FOR INSTANCE IT HAS
ENHANCED ITS DEMAND FORECAST BY
INCLUDING ONE IN THIRTY PEAK
FORECAST. TO ITS TWENTY TWENTY
INTEGRATED ENERGY POLICY
REPORT. THE CDC IS ALSO
EXTENDING THE FORECAST TO COVER
FIFTEEN YEAR HORIZON INSTEAD OF
A TEN YEAR HER EYES AND IT IS
UTILIZING CURRENT MODELS TO
IMPROVE OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE LIKELIHOOD OF EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS AS WELL AS
EXPANDING HOURLY FORECASTS TO
EXAMINE A WIDER RANGE OF
WEATHER PATTERNS. THE CDC ALSO
LET OUR WORK ON PLANNING
CONTINGENCIES WHICH HAVE BEEN
UTILIZED THIS SUMMER HELLO AYSO
IS PART IT IS INCENTIVE FOR
HOURLY REFINED PRICE SIGNALS TO
BE MORE ACCURATE SET A MINIMUM
STATE OF CHARGE FOR BATTERIES
SUBSTITUTED SUPPLY PLANNING
SUPPLY DURING PLANNED OUTAGES
AND STREAMLINE THE GRID
INTERCONNECTION PROCESS TO
EXPEDITE NEW SUPPLY. HAS ALSO
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND NEIGHBORING
BALANCING AUTHORITIES TO ENSURE
COORDINATION AND CLEAR CHANNELS
OF COMMUNICATIONS. HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED HOWEVER IN THE IN
OF THE CHANGE CLIMATE ARE
CHALLENGING EVEN THESE BEST
EFFORTS AND HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO PLACE ADDITIONAL STRAIN ON
ELECTRIC GRID THIS SUMMER AND
BEYOND AS WE ALL HAVE
EXPERIENCED FIRST HAND THE
ACCELERATION OF CLIMATE CHANGE
HAS CREATED EXTREME AND
UNPREDICTABLE HE INTENSE
DROUGHTS AND WILDFIRES ACROSS
THE WEST. ALL OF WHICH ARE MORE
FREQUENT MORE INTENSE AND LEAD
TO AID AT EIGHT ATTITUDES MAY
STRESS ON A LECTURE ON THE
ELECTRIC GRID ESPECIALLY DURING
CRITICAL HOURS OF THE DAY THE
COMMISSION'S GONNA WALK US
THROUGH THESE AND OTHER
CHANGING CONDITIONS EFFORTS TO
CONTINUE TO PROBLEM SOLVE IN
REAL TIME AS WE WORK TO GET
AHEAD OF THE PROBLEM STILL FOR
S. AS WELL AS OUTLINED THE
ACTION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION. WHICH
WILL STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S
POSITION TO MAINTAIN ELECTRIC
RELIABILITY THIS SUMMER AND
FALL AS WE CONTINUE TO INJURE
DRY AND HOT CONDITIONS. AND THE
HEIGHTENED RISK OF WILDFIRE BUT
BEFORE I HAND IT OFF TO
COMMISSION BELINDA I WANT TO BE
CLEAR OUR WORK TOWARD OUR CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE IS MOVING
FORWARD. AND WILL ONLY
ACCELERATE IN THE MONTHS AND
YEARS TO COME. THE RECORD HEAT
EVENTS AND SEVERE DROUGHT WE
HAVE SEEN ACROSS THE WEST THIS
SUMMER SHIP TO STRENGTHEN OUR
RESOLVE AND COMMITMENT TO
DELIVER A CLEAN AND RELIABLE
ELECTRIC GRID THE ORGANIZATIONS
HERE TODAY CONTINUED TO
COLLABORATE ON CRITICAL
PLANNING OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT TO
BUILD AN ELECTRIC SYSTEM THAT
WILL HELP IT WILL MEET OUR 100%
IN CLEAN ENERY GOALS.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO LEAD
THE NATION AND I DARE SAY THE
WORLD IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
RENEWABLE RESOURCES DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES INNOVATIVE
DEMAND RESPONSE. AND
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO. S.
IS ESSENTIAL TO PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS HOWEVER IN OUR
ECONOMY DETERRING CATASTROPHIC
CLIMATE CHANGE. AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK MY ORGANIZATIONAL
PARTNERS FOR THE WORK WE HAVE
DONE AND MUST CONTINUE TO DO
AND AGAIN I THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION. I
DON'T NOW TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE CDC. COMMISSIONER
SEVEN BELINDA THANK YOU WE'LL
HEAR FROM COMMISSIONER STEPHEN
GUNTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON ON OUR LIST HERE THE
SALES LICENSE ALI AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND TALK TO
SOME OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE-
DONE AND LEGALLY. OUR WORK
SIXTY HOURS. HI MY NAME IS
LINDA I AM A COMMISSIONER OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION AND
CURRENTLY LEADING. SEATING FOR
LIABILITY EFFORTS AFTER THE
EXTREME HEAT ON PUBLIC SUMMER
THE END OF COMMISSION COMMITTED
TO THE BALLOT OF ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
RELIABILITY AND TO SUPPORT
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS. AND
THAT'S BUDGET MENTIONED A
CONTINGENCY PLAN AND YOU
COMMISSION ASK THAT LED TO SOME
pESTIMATE THE POTENTIAL GAP
BETWEEN SUPPLY AND DEMAND UNDER
AVERAGE AS WELL AS EXTREME
WEATHER CONDITIONS SIMILAR TO
THOSE AT THE NEXT MEETING IN
TWENTY TWENTY. TO RESPOND FOR
THE ACTUAL CONTINGENCIES THAT
HELPS A BIT ANALYSIS WHAT
PRESIDENT AT AN INTEGRATED
ENERGY PLANNING REPORT-
WORKSHOP- WORKSHOP WAS JOINTLY
HELD. BY THE CCC PSE AND QUESO.
IN MAINE AND IDENTIFIED A
POTENTIAL SHORTFALL OF UP. TO
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
FOLLOWING THE UNEXPECTED
WEATHER EVENTS IN JUNE OF THIS
YEAR AND EVERYBODY UPDATED
INFORMATION ON CROP CONDITIONS
SEEM TO STOP UPDATED THE
ANALYSIS OF THE LATEST DEMAND
AND SUPPLY CONDITIONS THE
UPDATE UNDERTAKEN BY SEA TO
STOP TALKING TO COME TO THE
IMPACT OF DROUGHT ON HYDRO
GENERATION AND ALSO ASSUMED.
I'M CONTRACTED IMPORTS WOULD
NOT BE AVAILABLE DUE TO EXTREME
HEAT EVENTS THROUGHOUT THE WEST
END OR WIFI AND LIMITING THE
ABILITY TO HOUSTON PARKS ADULT
CONTINGENCY MEASURES ARE IN
ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENT FOR THE
REST OF THE SUMMER GENESEE
STAFF PROJECT THAT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE CALIFORNIA IS
THE SYSTEM. COULD POTENTIALLY
EXCEED AND UP TO THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF SHORTFALL
IN SEPTEMBER IN THE EVENT OF
EXTREME CONDITIONS. GIVING
CLIMATE GIVEN EXTREME
CONDITIONS INCLUDING CONTINUED
AND MORE SEVERE DROUGHT AND
ACCOUNTING FOR CURRENTLY PLAN
TO TIGHTEN UP OUR PLANS. FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND I
LOVE THOSE SPECIES THAT
PROJECTED SHORTFALL OF UP TO
FIVE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
IN THE EVENT OF EXTREME HEAT. I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE WORD-
EXTREME CONDITIONS OVER THE
LAST YEAR AND THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS THE STATE ENERGY
AGENCIES HAVE WORKED CLOSELY
TOGETHER TO CARRY OUT MEDIA
FACTIONS WITH THE INTENT OF
MAINTAINING ELECTRICAL
DELIGHTED TO SUMMER AND GOING
FORWARD. DURING THE JUNE AND
JULY STRESSED CONDITIONS
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ISSUED TWO
SEPARATE EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATIONS TO HELP SHORE UP
CONTINGENCY MEASURES AND
SUPPORT TO QUIT. BUT JULY
THIRTIETH PROCLAMATION FOR THE
SCREEN LINE THE ABILITY FOR THE
AGENCIES TODEPEND ON THE
CONTINGENCIES. THAT WOULD
ALIGHT UPON IN JUNE AND JULY
AND FURTHER. PROVIDES TOOLS TO
EXPAND ON THOSE CONTINGENCIES.
CAN YOU ACTUALLY HELP LINE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION ARE BEING TAKEN
OUTOF ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION AND
A BACKSTOP MEASURES. ON THE
BACKSTOP MEASURES DESIGNED TO
KEEP THE POWER FLOWING USING
WHAT IS NOT EXPECTED TO BE A
DRYER HOTTER AND LOOKING TO
SUMMER AND FALL. AS WELL AS
EVEN MORE HEIGHTENED. BY FIVE
SIX AND YEAH PROBABLY CREATE A
NEW PROGRAM THAT PRO TODAY
PAYMENTS TO CUSTOM WHO TO BACK
UP ONLY ONE IMMINENT ENERGY
SHORTFALL IS LIKELY EVEN IN A
CASE LIKE SOCKS AND ALL THE
OTHER EMERGENCY MEASURES IT'LL
EAT QUALITY FOR POWER PLANT
SHIPS AND PORTABLE GENERATORS
TO OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ONLY IN THE CASE
WHICH IS A GOOD MORNING
INDICATING AN ELECTRICITY
SHORTFALL IMMINENT DUE TO
EXTREME HEAT PRODUCED CAPACITY
PORTABLE THE PROCLAMATION
ENSURES TRACKING AND REPORTING
OF EMISSIONS IMPACT AND DIRECTS
THE AGENT RESOURCES BOARD TO
DEVELOP A MITIGATION PLAN
INCLUDING PROGRAMS TO IMPROVE
AIR QUALITY IN COMMUNITIES. AND
TO REDUCE. THE COST AND
POPULATIONS YEAH COMMISSION
IDENTIFY ACTION TO ACCELERATE
ACHIEVING THE STATE'S 100%
CLEAN ENERGY MANDATE THE LATEST
PERMITTING AND WAIVE CERTAIN
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
CLEAN ENERGY PROJECTS AND LARGE
COMPANY GENERATION CC ALREADY
APPROVED SOME OF THESE PROCESS
CHANGES AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION MEETING LAST WEEK
POPULATION ALSO LEVERAGES THE
PURCHASING POWER OF THE STATE
TO ASSIST WITH PROCUREMENT OF
MATERIALS GOODS AND SERVICES
NECESSARY FOR PROJECTS LIKE YOU
TO BE ONLINE BY OCTOBER THIRTY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR. THAT WOULD
EXPAND ENERGY SUPPLY AND
STORAGE TO RESPOND TO ENERGY
SUPPLY SHORTAGES CAUSED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE. WE W. R. HAD
PROCURED I DIDN'T PLAN TO
PROCURING MOBILE GENSET. FOR
TWO EXISTING SITE- WANTED
CALPINE GREENLEAF AND THE OTHER
GIRLS WILL ENERGY PARK. WHICH
WOULD HAVE PUT TOGETHER OKAY
ABOUT FOUR OF THESE MOBILE
GENSET TOTALING TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MEGAWATTS. AND I'M
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE AND FROM
FROM THE D. W. R. TECHNOCRATIC
TO GO INTO ANY DETAILS ON THOSE
QUESTIONS. THE GOVERNOR ALSO
REQUESTED THE CBSE TO EXERCISE
THE POWERS TO EXPAND DEMAND AND
SUPPLIES AND RESOURCES FOR NEXT
SUMMER THE CDC HAS ALREADY
RESPONDED BY THE INITIATING IT
SOMEWHAT A LOT OF THE
PROCEEDINGS. FOR THE PURPOSES
OF INCLUDING THE PROCUREMENT OF
THESE ENERGY SOURCES FOR SUMMER.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
THREE. THE PROBLEM IS ALSO THE
CASE TAKES TO EXPAND INTO THE
TIMES WE TO THE PRE OTHER KEY
STRATEGY AND ACTION WERE TAKEN
TO ENSURE TO LIVE THIS AND NEXT
SOMEBODY WELL WITH ANYTHING
THAT WAS GO TOWARD A EXTENDING
IT HOW MEGAWATT SUPPORT COME
SMART A LADY PICK COLLECTIVE.
FOR ALSO WORKING TO DEAL ON
FEDERAL WAIVER BECAUSE POWER TO
ENSURE WE ARE ABLE TO. THE AND-
CRITICAL UNDER OF THE KIND HE
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION THAT
I WILL HAND IT OFF TO GET ME IN
THERE. PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
KALISPELL WELCOME MR MEASURE.
WE HAVE WITH US PRESIDENT CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM. OPERATOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY JUST WANNA.
INFORM THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AFTER THEIR STATE
OPENING STATEMENTS WILL. GOING
TO QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS TO-
OF. THE- PRESIDENTS OF. OF THE
P. C. AND THE COMMISSIONER.
BUDDHA AND- THE SEA EAGLE ME-
MR MAIN SIR- SO IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THEM ON THE
SUBJECT. OF THE EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS- SO MISMANAGED OR IF
YOU'RE PREPARED THANK YOU FOR
JOINING THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHARLIE SO I PLACED
YOUR DOLLY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT
THE RELIABILITY OF OUR
ELECTRICAL GRID I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF MEETING SOME OF YOU
OVER THE PAST YEAR BU THIS IS
MY FIRST TIME APPEARING BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE. AND I
APPRECIATE BEING WITH YOU TODAY
AS A NATIVE SAN FRANCISCO I
KNOW HOW MUCH YOU AND THE
PEOPLE OF OUR STATE CARE ABOUT
COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE. WHAT
ABOUT HAVING ACCESS TO RELIABLE
AND AFFORDABLE ENERGY. AS YOU
MAY KNOW EARLIER IN THE YEAR
WHEN I WAS ASKED ABOUT OUR
SUMMER READING THIS. I
EXPRESSED GUARDED OPTIMISM THAT
THE ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENT AND
OTHER CHANGES WE PUT IN PLACE
IN ADVANCE OF THE SUMMER. AT
POSITION US BETTER THAN LAST
YEAR. BUT AS WE'VE SEEN. AND AS
PRESIDENT PATRICK COMMISSIONER
GOING TO HAVE TO MENTION. OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS WITH
ADDITIONAL RECORD HIGH
TEMPERATURES. UNPRECEDENTED
WILDFIRES. PERSISTENT DROUGHT
AND DECLINING HYDRO CONDITIONS
WE CLEARLY HAVE MOVED INTO A
NEW NORMAL. IT IS REQUIRED
EXTRAORDINARY ACTIONS TO
BALANCE ELECTRICITY SUPPLY AND
DEMAND. AND MAINTAIN
RELIABILITY FOR CALIFORNIANS
DURING THE FIRST WEEK OF JULY
IN COORDINATION WITH THE C. P.
C. AND C. E. C. THE I SO
TRIGGERED WHAT IS KNOWN AS OUR
BACKSTOP.PROCUREMENT
AUTHORITY. THAT IS ESSENTIALLY
AN EMERGENCY MECHANISM THAT
ALLOWS US TO DIRECTLY PROCURE
ENERGY WHEN THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN THE
UNDERLYING ASSUMPTIONS BEHIND
THE STATE'S RESOURCE ADEQUACY
USING THAT AUTHORITY WE WENT
INTO THE MARKET YOU WERE ABLE
TO SECURE APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MEGAWATT
HOUR FOR THE MONTH OF JULY. SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MEGAWATTS FOR THE
MONTH OF AUGUST. AND SIXTY
SEVEN MEGAWATTS FOR THE MONTH
OF SEPTEMBER. THE EXTRA
CAPACITY HAS BEEN HELPFUL BUT
EVEN WITH THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WE STILL FIND
OURSELVES IN THE MIDDLE OF
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING GREAT
CONDITIONS. KIND OF CULMINATING
ON JULY NINTH WHEN THE BOOTLEG
FIRE IN OREGON CUT OFF THE
MAJORITY OF POWER SUPPLY FROM
THE PACIFIC NORTHWEST IN
CALIFORNIA GIVEN THE CONDITIONS
WERE CONTINUING TO DETERIORATE
IN THE COMING RECENTLY AND
PREDICTABLE WE APPRECIATE
GOVERNOR SINCE EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION ISSUED ON JULY
THIRTIETH. THE ACTIONS OUTLINED
IN THE PROCLAMATION WILL GIVE
US ACCESS TO NEW TOOLS SUCH AS
ADDITIONAL BACKUP GENERATION.
WHICH WILL OF COURSE ONLY BE
USING ARE THE MOST STRESSED
RATE CONDITIONS. WE ARE ALSO
VERY MUCH AWARE THAT SOME OF
THESE RESOURCES WILL RESULT IN
INCREASED POLLUTION WE'RE
COMMITTED TO FOLLOWING A
LOADING QUARTER APPROACH WHICH
WILL ALLOW FOR THE USE OF
CLEANER RESOURCES. BEFORE
DURING YOUR OPTIONS. THE NEW
DEMAND RESPONSE TOOLS BEING
DEVELOPED BY THE STATE WILL
ALSO PROVIDE SOME RELIEF DURING
EXTREMELY STRESS FREE
CONDITIONS WE APPRECIATE THE
SENSE OF URGENCY AND
DECISIVENESS BUT THE GOVERNOR
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH WE ARE NOW
ABOUT TWO THIRDS F THE WAY
THROUGH THE SUMMER. WE NOTE
THAT EXTREMELY STRESSFUL
CONDITIONS TO PLAY OUT AGAIN IN
THE WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD. AND
WE OF COURSE NEED TO BE
PREPARED BY THE STATE TAKES ON
THE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TASK
OF BRINGING NEW CAPACITY ON
SHORTBREAD. TO SOLVE
CHALLENGING THAT KEEP YOUR
SHOES TO KERR FOR US AFTER
SUNSET ALONG WITH THE C. P. C.
IN C. C. B. I. S. O. REMAINS
EXTREMELY FOCUSED ON DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
WE BRING THOSE RESOURCES PART
OF THE GRID. ALL THE SUPPLY
SIDE IN THE JUST. INSIDE IN THE
MONTHS AND YEARS AHEAD. THAT
WAY WE CAN TAKE OUR GREAT AWAY
FROM THE EDGE OF THE STORE MORE
HEALTHY RESERVE MARGIN FOR THE
STATE. I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A
BIT MORE ABOUT TWO AREAS THAT%
WILL BE A MAJOR FOCUS FOR THE I
SO IN GETTING THIS DONE. FIRST
WE'VE IDENTIFIED SET OF
SPECIFIC LOCATIONS ON THE
TRANSMISSION GRID. WHERE THERE
IS EXISTING CAPACITY THAT CAN
BE UTILIZED IN THE SHORT TERM.
TO BRING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
OUR SYSTEM. PARTICULARLY
BATTERY STORAGE WHICH IS
ALREADY PROVEN TO BE VERY
HELPFUL IN DEALING WITH BUT NET
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES THE
CALIFORNIA CHASEN'S. AND OVER
THE LONGER TERM TO OUR NEWLY
LAUNCHED TWENTY YEAR
TRANSMISSION OUTLOOK PROCESS.
WE INTEND TO PROVIDE SPECIFIC
AND ACTIONABLE TRANSMISSION
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE CDC
NCPC. THE GUY PROCUREMENTS IN
THE YEARS AHEAD. TO HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET ITS SP ONE
HUNDRED GOALS. IT IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL FOR STATE POLICY
MAKERS AND UTILITIES TO ACHIEVE
AS MUCH ALIGNMENT AS POSSIBLE.
ABOUT THE CRITICAL NEED FOR
TRANSMISSION TO HELP CALIFORNIA
MEET THOSE CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
I BELIEVE I CAN STATE
UNEQUIVOCALLY THAT ADDITIONAL
TRANSMISSION WILL BE
INDISPENSABLE IN ENABLING
CALIFORNIA TO MEET ITS LONG
TERM DECARBONISATION TARGETS.
TRANSMISSIONS OF ELEMENT
REQUIRES LONG LEAD TIME SO WE
MUST ACCELERATE OUR ACTIONS
NOW. TO BE PREPARED FOR CLEAN
ENERGY DEVELOPMENT REQUIREMENTS
IN THE YEARS AHEAD. AND TO
DEVELOP THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE. AND LEAST REGRETS
TRANSMISSION OPTIONS FOR THE
STATE. FINALLY I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE IDEA SO
WE'RE ALSO VERY MOTIVATED TO
PLAY A VERY CONSTRUCTIVE ROLE.
IN FURTHER ENABLING DEMAND
RESPONSE DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES TO BE A MORE
SIGNIFICANT PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICITY
PORTFOLIO AND STRATEGY. WE'RE
VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE NEW WORK
HAPPENING AT BOTH THE CPC AND
THE. CC ON THESE TOPICS.
INSTEAD READY TO BE A SORT OF
OUR MAKE SURE HE RESOURCE PLAY
A MAJOR ROLE IN ENERGY FUTURE
ALL OF US AT THE I. S. AND
STAND READY TO DO WE CAN TO
HELP THE STATE THE SCREEN AND
PROJECT IT'S NOT RELIABLE
ENOUGH FOR FASHION AND I TOO
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION WITH MY PARTNERS
AT THE C. P. C. C. C. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOUR WAY SO BY SURE
DOLLY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR TENNIS ON THESE CRITICAL
ISSUES. AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THE SEVENTY TWO. THIS
CONCLUDES OUR OPENING
STATEMENTS AND WE'RE ALL HAPPY
TO ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS THAT
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND COME TO
MEMBERS QUESTIONS I WANT TO ASK
A FEW QUESTIONS RELATED TO.
IMPORTS OF ENERGY IMPORTS ARE
RELATED TO TRANSGENDER G.
TRANSMISSION AND ALSO RELATED
TO- SOME RECENT RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE RECEIVE THIS PAST PAST
MARCH FROM THE WESTERN ELECTRIC
COORDINATING COUNCIL AND THE
FIRST QUESTION OF COURSE WOULD
BE RELATING TO IMPORTS ONE OF
THE AREAS OFCONCERN. IS THE
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
WITH IMPORTANCE ESPECIALLY
THEIR RELIABILITY DURING
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE WESTERN
REACHES AN EXPERIENCE YOU TOO
HIGH PEAK PERIODS IN THE WINTER
AND IN THE SUMMER AS A RESULT
CALIFORNIA MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
RELY ON THESE IMPORTS IN THE
SUMMER. AS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
RE- RELY ON IN PREVIOUS YEARS
CAN YOU SPEAK. MORE TO THIS
CHALLENGE AND HOW YOU ARE
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE IN ANY OF
THE WORK RECENTLY. CERTAINLY
SURE WISH I'D BE I'D BE HAPPY
TO START OUT BY ASKING THE
QUESTION IT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION AND I THINK RIGHT ON
POINT. AND IT HIGHLIGHTS THE
TREMENDOUS IMPORTANCE OF STRONG
COORDINATION BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND THE ADJACENT REGIONS FROM
WHICH WE BOTH. IMPORT AND
EXPORT ELECTRICITY BECAUSE
THEIR SIGNIFICANT
INTERDEPENDENCE BETWEEN THESE
REGIONS WE HAVE SEEN IN THE
OFFICE AND OVER THE LAST YEAR
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN IT GETS
SIMULTANEOUSLY VERY HOT. ALL
APART J. SYSTEM BY REGIONS AND
NOW WE ARE FORCED TO SPEND MUCH
MORE TIME COORDINATING CLOSELY
WITH THE TEAMS IN THE NORTHWEST
CARPOOL WITH FOLKS IN THE
DESERT SOUTHWEST SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW THE LOADED
RESOURCE BALANCE IS CHANGING
THEIR SERVICE TERRITORIES.
THESE OTHER UTILITIES ARE ALSO
UNDERTAKING SIGNIFICANT
DECARBONISATION OBJECTIVES
pAND GAS PLANT RETIREMENTS
HAPPENING IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
WEST AS WELL. AND SO WE'RE
HAVING TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME
NOW BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW THOSE
CHANGES MAY IMPACT THE AMOUNT
OF ELECTRICITY AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA AND JUDGE ADJUST OUR
PLANNING ASSUMPTIONS
ACCORDINGLY THERE HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUS VALUE OVER THE YEARS
FOR CALIFORNIA. J. SHOULD
REGIONS BE ABLE TO EXCHANGE
ENERGY WHEN WE HAVE A SURPLUS
WE CAN SHIP IT WHEN THEY HAVE A
SURPLUS WE CAN IMPORT IT BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO BE ATTENDED TO THE
CHANGES. AND MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
AS NECESSARY THANK THANK YOU
FOR THAT IMPORTANT QUESTION.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
ANSWER DID ANYONE WANT TO ADD
ON TO THAT AND MAYBE- FROM PC
OR FROM THE. ENERGY COMMISSION
ANYTHING AT ALL DON'T MISS
CHECK THINGS THAT PRESS AND CEO
MEANS- EXPLAIN THE SIX. WELL WE
HAPPEN FOR SEVENTY DEGREES
IMPORTS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS- WITH THE CHANGING OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND I MEAN NOT JUST
THE ENVIRONMENT BUT THE
NEIGHBORING STATES. ENVIRONMENT
AS WELL. AND I THINK THAT- WITH
SOME OF THOSE CHANGES WE HAVE
REALIZED THAT WE- WE DO NEED
TO. BE MINDFUL OF ALL OF OUR
NEXT. TIME THERE IS A NEED SO-
I THINK. THE THREE ENERGY
AGENCIES HAVE HEIGHTENED
AWARENESS AND I'M CERTAINLY NOT
MAKING ADJUSTMENTS IN OUR
PLANNING PROCESS. TO REALIZE
SOME OF THE CHANGING US
SITUATIONS THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING WITH THE IMPORTS.
THANK YOU- THE NEXT. QUESTION
RELATED TO TRANSMISSION MY
PROVIDE A OF TRANSMISSION
PROJECTS AND- THAT OF THE-
CLEAN- AMERICAN CLEAN POWER HAS
NOT NOTED. ARE STYMIED INCITING
OR INNER CONNECTION OR OTHER
COMMITTEE IN- PROCESSES SO I
UNDERSTAND THE C. P. U. C. N.
CHI SOURCE ARE- THE STAFFS ARE
REVIEWING THIS LIST AND WILL
PROVIDE US AN UPDATE AS A
FOLLOW UP TO TODAY'S HEARING SO
BUT HOWEVER. I WELCOME YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF FOCUSING ON TRANSMISSION
RELATED ISSUES AS- ANOTHER.
THAT WOULD BE- HELPFUL FOR US
HERE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUES AND CHALLENGES WITH
TRANSMISSION IF ANY GIVEN.
THERE WAS A KRANZ CONSTRAIN
TRANSMISSION DURING THE AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY OUTAGES SO DO YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON HOW YOU'D
LIKE TO SHARE ON THAT POINT
SPECIFICALLY. I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO START I JUST BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE PRINCIPAL RESPONSIBILITY
FOR TRANSMISSION OF PLANNING A
WITHIN THE STATE YES- SO WE
HAVE RECEIVED AN INQUIRY FROM
STAFF AND WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE CPC TO TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE
SPECIFIC ISSUES AND WILL BE.
REPORTING BACK TO YOU ON THOSE
QUESTIONS SHORTLY BUT AS I AS I
STATED ALSO IN IN MY OPENING
REMARKS YOU KNOW ANYWAYS I
SOMETIMES THINK OF
TRANSMISSION. REALLY IS THE
SORT OF GATEWAY TO THE FUTURE
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS THAT PIECE
OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT LINKS UP
SUPPLY. WITH DEMAND. HELPS US
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COLLABORATION
WITH OTHER REGIONS IT REALLY IS
GOING TO BE A CRITICAL PART. OF
THE STATE'S RESOURCE PORTFOLIO
IN THE FUTURE WHILE ALSO
OBVIOUSLY STAYING VERY
SENSITIVE TO COST FORTY BILLION
MAKING GOOD CHOICES SO WE WERE
VERY PLEASED. TO BE WORKING NOW
MUCH MORE CLOSELY WITH THE CDC
AND THE CPC. NOT ONLY IN THE
VERY SHORT TERM TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY THE PLACES
ON THE GRID WHERE WE HAVE SPARE
CAPACITY WHICH REALLY COME TO
THE TABLE NOW WITH CHAR CITED
VERY SPECIFIC AND PRAGMATIC
RECOMMENDATIONS. ON WHERE WE
WHERE WE THINK THE BEST
TRANSMISSION OPPORTUNITIES ARE
TO ACCESS THE CLEAN ENERGY.
CAPACITY RESOURCES CRITICAL TO
GETTING ONE GOAL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO GREATER PERSUASIONS
ABOUT THIS WITH THE STATE WE'RE
WORKING VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE
WE IDENTIFY THE SPECIFIC PAGE
POINTS IN SPECIFIC SETS OF
SOLUTIONS IN LOCKPORT WORKING
WITH YOU- AND MEMBERS OF YOUR
STAFF. TO TRY TO REALLY UNLOCK
CAPABILITY TRANSMISSION
OPPORTUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU. VERY MUCH.
THE WESTERN ELECTRIC
COORDINATING COUNCIL ISSUED ITS
OWN RECOMMENDATIONS THIS PAST
MARCH FOR THE BROADER WESTERN
REGION IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
AUGUST OUTAGES AND THE
CONSTRAINED GRIT I'M HOPING YOU
COULD PROVIDE A FOLLOW UP AS TO
WHAT THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS IF
ANY OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
BEING INCORPORATED INTO YOUR
ACTIONS IF THEY ARE NOT CAN WE
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY ARE NOT.
SPORTS FOR TODAY I'M WONDERING
IF YOU HAVE A GENERAL REACTION
TO THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS. AGAIN
I'M I'M HAPPY TO JUMP IN AND
PRESENT BACHELOR PROJECT
CONTRIBUTED A SKILL TREE OF
COURSE- BUT YES WE HAVE- WEDC
HAS BEEN OBVIOUSLY VERY
INTERESTED AS THE ENTITY IN THE
WEST UNITED STATES HAS.
OVERARCHING RESPONSIBILITY FOR
MONITORING THE STATUS OF
RELIABILITY ON THE WESTERN GRID
THEY WERE QUITE ATTENTIVE TO
WHAT HAPPENED LAST SUMMER IN
CALIFORNIA THEY PRODUCED A SET
OF FINDINGS WHICH LARGELY
CORROBORATED THE BASIC
TAKEAWAYS FROM OUR ANALYSIS.
THEY ALSO POINTED OUT AND
GETTING TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION
INSTRUMENT ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE CHANGES IN THE
RESOURCE PORTFOLIO ACROSS THE
WEST- AND QUITE FRANKLY. THEY
THINK THEY'VE INDICATED THAT
EVERY MAJOR SUB BASIN IN THE
WESTERN AND STATES. IS RELIANT
ON IMPORTS 21 DEGREES OR
ANOTHER. TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON
IN THEIR SERVICE TERRITORIES
AND THEY'RE EMPHASIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION INFORMATION. DATA
SHARING AND MUCH GREATER STATE
AWARENESS WITHIN THE REGIONS
FOR WHAT THE SUPPLY DEMAND
BALANCES FOR THE WHOLE WEST
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL PART OF AN
OVER ARCHING. MARKET FOOTPRINT
AND WE NEED TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER TO UNDERSTAND THOSE
FUNDAMENTALS AND LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES T SHARE ENERGY
CAPACITY TO WORK ON
TRANSMISSION DEVELOPMENT BUT
WE'RE IT WE'RE ALL FACING
SCARCITY AND SHORTAGES AND WE
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER. VERY
CONSERVATIVELY TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS FOR THE. ENTIRE WEST
NOT JUST CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWER TO HAVE AN EMAIL OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
ASK ANY QUESTIONS SENATOR DOLLY
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I HAD A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ON-
AS WE AS WE'VE SEEN THIS YEAR
AND THE PAST YEAR- YOU KNOW WE
WERE IN A DROUGHT. WE'RE ALSO
SEEING FIRE AND WE'RE ALSO
SEEING A TRANS WHAT WE'RE
TRANSFORMING FROM. WE'RE GONNA
SHUT DOWN NUCLEAR DIABOLOS
GONNA GO DOWN IN A COUPLE YEARS
US LIKE THREE THOUSAND I THINK
TWENTY HUNDRED MEGAWATTS AND
YOU TALKED ABOUT AT THE I. S.
O. U. YOU WERE ABLE TO SECURE A
COUPLE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS AT
THIS POINT AND SO WE'RE TRANCE
WE'RE WE'RE TRANSFORMING FROM
AN ENERGY SOURCE. THAT IS WHAT
IT WAS IS NATURAL GAS IT
NUCLEAR AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO I
HEARD YOU SAY BATTERIES HAS
THERE BEEN ANY ANALYSIS ON THE
COST AND RELIABILITY OF HOW HOW
WHAT THE COST TO THE RATEPAYERS
GONNA BE FOR BATTERY STORAGE TO
TAKE CARE OF US FROM WHEN THE
SUN IS NOT SHINING IN THE
WIND'S NOT BLOWING AND THE
WATER IS NOT FLOWING. IT'S
DIFFICULT IN THIS FORMAT AND
CHRISTOPHER TO EITHER I'M
PRESIDENT PATRICK COMMISSION
GRANDER THINGS LIKE OFFERING
OPTIONS ON THAT YES. HE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROCESS DOES EXACTLY THAT- LAST
YEAR DOLLY AND- WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT DIFFERENT
RATE IMPACTS- WE HAVE A
PROCEEDING THAT DOES THAT- THE
STRONGEST RATE IMPACTS
CURRENTLY REALLY. FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS FOR THE CUSTOMERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA R. ONE
LACK OF WILDFIRE MITIGATION AND
SHOOT TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION COSTS. BATTERY
STORAGE IT IS AS I THINK
PRESIDENT CEO MANGER ADDED
EARLIER IN HIS COMMENTS HAS
BEEN ENORMOUSLY SUCCESSFUL IN
HELPING US MAINTAIN GRID
RELIABILITY THIS SUMMER AND WE
HAVE EASIEST DECISIONS
SUPPORTED DIGITAL STORAGE IT IS
COMING ON LINE AS WE SPEAK- AND
WILL CONTINUE IN THE NEXT
SUMMER TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
THREE. AND IN THE FUTURE- IN
THE I. R. P. IN THE INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING THERE IS
MORE- STORAGE THAT WILL BE
ADDED ON TO THE SYSTEM MORE
STORAGE IS THERE ANY IS THERE
BEEN ANY ANALYSIS ON THE COST
OF STORAGE OF ONE MEGAWATT SO
THAT WE COULD DO THE MATH WHEN
WE WHEN WE FIGURE OUT HOW MANY
MEGAWATTS WE'RE GONNA BE SHORT
IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE GONNA PUT
IT INTO STORAGE- SO THAT THE
PUBLIC CAN UNDERSTAND GOING
FORWARD WHEN WE SHUT DOWN.
WHICH WE USED TO TALK ABOUT
GOING FROM COAL TO NATURAL GAS.
AND THAT WAS CLEANER AND NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GOING
TAKING AWAY NATURAL GAS ARENA
GO TO BATTERIES. SO IT'S AN N.
AS- WE WENT OFF OF COAL OUR
PRICES ESCALATED UP AND I'M
ASSUMING THEY'RE GOING TO GO UP
EVEN HIGHER. BUT WHEN WE GO TO
A DEGREE AT THAT HOUSE BATTERY
STORAGE. AND DOESN'T USE
NUCLEAR OR NATURAL GAS. YES IF
I MAY JUST BEFORE WE GO TO
ANSWER THAT ON IT THE POLICIES
OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE- AS
WELL AS AS THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
AND NUMEROUS- THREE
ADMINISTRATIONS HAS DETERMINED
ARE VERY STRONG GHG GOALS WHICH
WE ARE REACHING TO A VARIETY OF
RESOURCES BATTERIES BEING VERY
IMPORTANT TO IT AND IN SO DOING
REACHING US GHG GOALS WE ARE
RETIRING THE USE. OF THE
RESOURCES THAT INTERNET
GREENHOUSE GASES. SO IN
ATTEMPTING TO HOLD VERY TIGHT
TO THE GOALS THAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SELLER'S FLORES WE
ARE HAVING AN ENERGY MIX-
PROCURING AN ENERGY MIX THAT
INCLUDES BATTERIES IN TUCSON
VICE THIS DEVICE HERE TO YOUR
SPECIFIC QUESTION. ABOUT HAVE
WE CALCULATED THE COST OF THE-
COST OF A MEGAWATT BATTERY. I
NEED TO ASK AND RANDOLPH IS
THERE ANY CHARGES DOING MANY OF
OUR RATE STUDIES TO ADDRESS
THANK OU PRESIDENT BADGER ON
YES AND AT RANDOLPH THAT NEED
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR ENERGY
AND CLIMATE POLICY THE U. C.
YOU TOO THE- SPECIFIC COST OF
BATTERIES- THE WAY THE P. YOU
SEE WHEN THEY DO THE-
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROCESS LOOKS AT. IS THEY TAKE
THE COST OF VARIOUS- OPTIONS
VARIOUS RESOURCES THAT COULD BE
ME USED TO MEET OUR RELIABILITY
AND OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND
OPTIMIZES AGAINST US BUT WHEN
WE START TALKING ABOUT IN OUR
PROCUREMENT ORDERS- WHAT IS
NEEDED IN TERMS OF A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF STORAGE OF SOLAR.
WIND OF OFFSHORE WIND THAT IS
BASED ON OPTIMIZING- THE COST
IN PICKING THE LOW COST
PORTFOLIO ALL RIGHT WE ALSO
LOOK AT WHEN WE LOOK AT THAT-
IT IS CONSTRAINED BY THE-
ENVIRONMENTAL- POLICIES ARE SET
IN STATUTE- BUT THERE IS SOME
RANGE WITHIN THOSE
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY SO FOR
EXAMPLE- WE HAVE LOOKED AT THE
DIFFERENCES IN COST BETWEEN-
HAVING A PORTFOLIO ELECTRICAL
IN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S- A FORTY
SIX MILLION METRIC TONS. OF CO
TWO ALL THE WAY DOWN TO ONE AND
A DEBT- THIRTY MILLION METRIC
TONS IN THERE ARE COST
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN EACH ONE OF
THOSE- AND I CAN'T- RATTLES OFF
TOP OF MY HEAD BUT HAPPY TO
SHARE THOSE WITH YOU WITH YOUR
OFFICE- ADDITIONALLY THERE BEEN
A NUMBER OF- STUDIES DONE
OUTSIDE OF THE P. U. C. LOOKING
AT WHAT THE COST. OF MEETING.
THE CLIMBING GOALS WOULD BE OR
OPTIONS THE CLIMATE GOALS
INCLUDING THE SQ ONE HUNDRED
ANALYSIS THAT THE JOINT
AGENCIES HAVE DONE- AS REQUIRED
BY STATUTE- BUT TO NAME A FEW
OTHERS- A RECENT ANALYSIS DONE
BY THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES ON
WHAT ORGANIZING THEIR GRADE
WOULD COST- AND WON- BY THE
GOLDMAN SCHOOL- LOOKING AT IT.
YOU. KNOW NATIONAL COST OF
DECARBONISING THE IN ALL OF THE
STUDY FAIRLY CONSISTS SHOW THAT
THE OF TO- CARBON FREE OR AT
LEAST A 90% CARBON FREE
GRANITE- HE'S EITHER THE
MINIMUS OR SOME OF THE STUDIES
EVEN SHOW IT IS LESS EXPENSIVE.
THAN RELYING ON A GRID THAT
WOULD REQUIRE NEW- NEW CALL A
NEW NATURAL GAS VEHICLES THEN
AGAIN WE'RE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE VIDEOGRAPHY OF ALL
THESE REPORTS IF THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL I ALSO WANTED TO JUST
POINT OUT THAT IN S. B. THREE
FIFTY I BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS
THE OPTION TO CAL LARGE HYDRO
AS PART IS OUT PERCENT GOAL
AND- BUT WE'VE CHOSEN NOT TO
PUT IN HYDRO I BELIEVE THAT
THAT THERE HASN'T BEEN THOSE
SCENARIOS HAVEN'T BEEN PUT IN
AS PART OF THAT- 100% IS THAT.
CORRECT. YEAH SURE GOOD NOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO
THAT ABSOLUTELY AFTER SOME
BADGER- THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THOSE- QUESTIONS I JUST KIND OF
FAT BUILDING OFF OF WHAT AND
MATURE AND ALL KIND OF
MENTIONED. TIME SIMILAR TO HOW
THE MODELING IS DONE IN THE IRP
PROCESS AND AS WELL AS THE SP
ONE HUNDRED. JUST A FEW THINGS
TO NOTE- AS AS MISTER RANDOLPH
MENTIONED WE OPTIMIZE THEM AND
BASED ON YOU KNOW WE LOOK AT
ALL THE COST OF THE DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGIES AND THEN WE
OPTIMIZE BASED ON CONSTRAINTS-
TWO TO THE CLIMATES BECAUSE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE. AND THEN THE
LEAST COST PORTFOLIO THAT IT
THE LIABILITY AND SELECTED IT
AS A PLANNING ASSUMPTION FOR
THE FUTURE. SO BASED ON THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS RIGHT NOW ONE OF
THE CRITICISMS- OR FEEDBACK
WE'VE RECEIVED ESPECIALLY FROM
THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY- IS THAT IS OUR LACK
OF TREATMENT OF NON ENERGY
BENEFITS. ARE ARE KIND OF
COSTING DOUBT A CARBON- FOR
SPECIFIC TECHNOLOGIES- THAT
THAT MAY BE STILL IN MEETINGS
SO JUST WHEN I NOTE THAT EVEN
THOUGH WE TRY TO OPTIMIZE THE
COST. AND THE COST OF EXAMPLE
AND GAS LEAK WHICH HAVE BEEN
MISSIONS ARE NOT COMPLETELY
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT AS A PART OF
THE ANALYSIS. SECONDLY TO YOUR
POINT ON THEIR LARGE HYDRO
THANK YOU YOU'RE YOU'RE CORRECT
THAT IT'S NOT A PART OF. OUR PS
BUT IT IS A PART OF THE SP ONE
HUNDRED ZERO CARBON- TECHNOLOGY
LAST I DON'T WANT IT WHAT ARE
WE COUNTED IF PART OF THE
LARGEST IS THE BILL TO CARRY
WHITE- WE COUNT IF I CAN
FURTHER CLARIFY THAT IN TERMS
OF- ANALYSIS ON GETTING TO OUR-
TWENTY THIRTY ONE IS THE POINT
WE'RE MODELING OUT TO RIGHT
NOW- THE MODELING DOES ASSUME
THAT ALL EXISTING LARGE HYDRO-
CONTINUES- TO EXIST. ON INDIAN
THERE- IT DOES NOT ASSUME THAT
ANY NEW LARGE HYDRO WOULD BE
BUILT- OUT THERE- I'M NOT AWARE
OF HE- PROJECTS THAT ARE OUT
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED THAT
WOULD PRODUCE ENERGY ON WHERE
ONE'S THERE. WOULD BE USED FOR
WATER STORAGE OR OTHER PURPOSES
BUT WOULD PRODUCE VERY LITTLE
ENERGY. HOWEVER WHEN YOU LOOK
BEYOND THE 60% R. P. S. TARGET
AND START TALKING ABOUT- CARBON
FREE THE ASSUMPTION IS ALL THE
EXISTING LARGE HYDRO- WITHIN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE WEST
CONTINUES. TO BE UTILIZED TO
MEET THOSE GOALS THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. OKAY I WILL GO TO
SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU MISS
SHEARER I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS- ONE FOR THE I. A
SOUL- IF YOU HAVE YOUR POWER
FOR THIS SUMMER- SESSION AND I
CURED HUNDREDS OF MEGAWATTS
USING. THE CAPACITY GERMAN
MECHANISM- FOR THE SUMMER DUE
TO THESE EXTREME CONDITIONS AND
IT'S TRULY NECESSARY BUT CAN
YOU PLEASE GIVE US AN ESTIMATE
OF THE TOTAL COST OF
PROCUREMENT AND HOW IT WILL BE
SPREAD OUT. OVER ALL LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES BECAUSE THAT'S
NEVER EXPLAINED IN A CHEESY THE
POOR FOLKS WHO WIND UP PAYING
FOR THIS SO PLEASE SHARE HOW
THIS IS GOING TO BE EXPRESSED
SHARE THE COSTS ARE SPREAD OUT
OVER ALL LOAD SERVING AREAS YES
THANK YOU SENATOR- I WILL GET
BACK TO YOU WHICH TEAM AT THE
VERY VERY LATEST ESTIMATE
SPECIFIC DOLLAR VALUE OF THE
PROCUREMENT FOR JULY. AUGUST
AND SEPTEMBER- BUT I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THE APPROACH TO COST
ALLOCATION FOR THAT IS THAT
THOSE COSTS ARE SPREAD ACROSS
BELOW BELOW IN THE SWITCH IN
THE CALIFORNIA ISO BALANCING
AUTHORITY. THIS IS THIS IS.
UNDERTAKEN AS PART OF WHAT'S
KNOWN AS OUR SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
PREPARATORY WORK UNDERLYING
ASSUMPTIONS THE PLANNING.
MODELING HOW TO JUSTIN AND WE
TOOK THOSE ACTIONS ORDINATION
CPCC SEE THAT WHAT WE SPREAD
ACROSS ALL THOSE ENTITIES AND-
OUR BALANCING AUTHORITY AND
CERTAINLY WE CERTAINLY DON'T
LIKE TO HAVE TO USE THAT TOOL
GIVEN THE CONDITIONS WE ARE
FACING HOW WE FOUND IT
NECESSARY R. M. I FULL OF
QUESTIONS FOR THE PC. OUR
RESOURCE ADEQUACY IS THE ORDER
OF THE DAY AFTER THE TWO
THOUSAND ONE- ENERGY CRISIS AND
ON. THE SERVICE- PROVIDING AND
MAINTAINING- RELIABILITY SO WE
TRULY UNDERSTAND IT SINCE THE
CENTRAL. BUT IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS A NUMBER RESOURCE
ADEQUACY CITATIONS AND FINES
HAVE INCREASED- QUITE
DRAMATICALLY IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN I THINK THERE WERE
THREE CITATIONS LAST YEAR ALONE
THERE WERE TWENTY. I'M CURIOUS-
COULD YOU EXPLAIN- WHAT YOU'RE
DOING TO REDUCE- THESE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY VIOLATIONS AND HA. P.
U. C. A RECENT DECISION AND
RESOURCE ADEQUACY OF
PROCEEDINGS IMPROVE THE
PROGRAM- BECAUSE MANY FEEL IT'S
CHEAPER TO PAY THE FINE. AND
CITATION THEN TO PROCURE THIS
POWER SO WHAT TOOL ARE YOU
GOING TO USE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE- COMPANIES ARE ACQUIRING
THE POWER VERSUS JUST STICK IN
THE FINE SENATOR BRADFORD
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE
HAS BEEN AN INCREASE IN ARMED
RESOURCE ADEQUACY FINE AND-
FRANKLY I FIND IT PRETTY
DISTURBING- AND PARTICULARLY IN
THE SITUATION THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN THIS YEAR OR NEXT
YEAR. AND FRANKLY FOR THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS BOTH DEMAND RESPONSE
IN RESOURCE ADEQUACY ARE
CRITICAL AND CRITICAL TO
KEEPING IT RELIABILITY OF THE
GRID- IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE WE
DOING ABOUT IT SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC THINGS THAT WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK AT IT'S A
GREATER FINE- IN TERMS OF THE
PENALTY FOR. WHICH SHE WILL
DESCRIBE SOME OF THE ENTITIES
THAT ARE CONSIDERED PART OF THE
RESOURCE ADEQUACY PORTFOLIO
FIND IT EASIER TO PAY THE FINE
THAT THEY DO TO- PROVIDE THE
ENERGY SO I DON'T KNOW AND YOU
WANT TO ADD A COUPLE THINGS TO
THAT I'M SURE AGAIN. THANK YOU
PRESIDENT DR- YEAH I MEAN IT IS
AN EXCELLENT POINT THE- THE
FINES FOR VIOLATION OF RESOURCE
ADEQUACY AT THIS POINT ARE
SOMETIMES LOWER THAN THE ACTUAL
COST IN THE OPEN MARKET GOING
OUT AND BUYING CAPACITY AND SO
WE ARE- YOU KNOW WE DO SUSPECT
THAT SOME LOADS ARE ENTITIES
WOULD RATHER JUST PAY THE FINE
THEY GO OUT THERE AND BUY
RESOURCE ADEQUACY ON THE FLIP
SIDE I AM AWARE OF- MANY OF THE
ONES ENTITIES BOTH- YOU READERS
AND I ARE USED TO CONTINUE TO
BUY RESOURCE ADEQUACY AND AVOID
THE PENALTIES EVEN IF THE COST
OF COMPLIANCE IS HIGHER THAN
THE PENALTIES- IT BRINGS INTO
QUESTION KIND OF A RE LOOK AT
THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY SET UP AS
A WHOLE- YOUR SPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THAT IN THIS DAY
AND AGE WE NOW HAVE OVER THIRTY
DIFFERENT- LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES THAT NEED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY PROGRAM. WHERE WHEN
THE PROGRAM WAS DESIGNED- AND
IT WAS A SMALL HANDFUL OF IT
HE'S ACTIVE PARTICIPATE IN IT
SO THE DYNAMICS HAVE CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE YEARS. IN
OUR RESOURCE ADEQUACY
PROCEEDING THERE IS A TRACK
THAT IS LOOKING AT EXACTLY THAT
QUESTION ON DO WE NEED TO-
THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT A DO WE
NEED TO HOW DO WE REDESIGNED
THE PROGRAM TO BETTER MATCH-
THE CURRENT RETAIL AND
WHOLESALE MARKETS ARE OUT
THERE. UNFORTUNATELY I HOPE AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE- THE TITLE N.
OF REDESIGNING A MARKET LIKE
THIS IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE CAN
DO OVERNIGHT- IT'S BEEN BEING
DISCUSSED FOR. THE PAST NINE
MONTHS OR SO THROUGH A SERIES
OF WORKSHOPS AND HELMETS FOR
PARTIES- IT WILL LIKELY
CONTINUE FOR ANOTHER YEAR-
BEFORE. THERE'S A FULLY
DEVELOPED STAFF PROPOSAL ARE
USEFUL WITH I THINK YOUR EX
WITH IS CLEAR THE PROBLEM THAT
IS EXISTED IN THE PROBLEM THAT
EXISTS AND THIS WHOLE UTILITY
SPACE RIGHT NOW IS. BEING
CALLED BY THIS LEGISLATURE A
LEGISLATOR WHO SHOULD'VE BEEN
DELVING IN. THE SPACE TO THE
DEGREE THAT THEY ARE UP AND WE
SHOULD ALL LISTEN TO THE
EXPERTS WHO HAVE DONE THIS FOR
ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS BUT- WE
HAVE A LEGISLATORS AND- WHO.
WANT TO REDESIGN THIS MARKET
AND- IT'S RADICALLY CHANGED IT
AND IT MAKES IT ALMOST I'M YOU
KNOW IT'S A LOT TO SAY
COMPLIANCE RELIABILITY IT'S
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE WITH ALL
THESE DIFFERENT MODES SERVICE
INITIALLY EXAMPLE CC AGE WHO
ARE REALLY JUST A PROCURE A
PROP UP OUR POWER BUT ONE OF
MASQUERADE AT THE CHILLY SO WE
HELP CAUSES PROBLEMS. THANK
YOU. NOW SENATOR JOSH BECKER.
THANK YOU CHAIR BUT MY QUESTION
FOR THE PERFECTION P. U. C- ARE
WE MOVING FAST ENOUGH TO
INCENTIVIZE AND FAIRLY
COMPENSATE DEMAND RESPONSE
PROVIDERS IT SEEMS LIKE WE SAW
HIM FIX THE PROBLEMS THAT. I'M
CONNECTING OTHERS IDENTIFIED
LAST YEAR WHEN THE BASS LINES
ARE SET BASED ON DAYS THAT ARE
UNLIKE THE DAYS ARE SHORT JUST
HAPPEN AND THEY'RE NOT BEING.
COMPENSATED FOR REAL DEMAND
REDUCTIONS. I WILL. SPEAK TO
THIS BUT I ALSO AM- SHARE SOME
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH I SO ON.
SOME OF THE PLANNING. PROCESS
BUT- WE HAVE MADE MANY
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE DEMAND
RESPONSE PROGRAMS AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER SIR- I THINK
ONE OF THE SPECIFIC THINGS THAT
MAYBE. IT'S BEING ALLUDED TO MY
OWN CONNECT WHICH I'LL JUST
TOUCH ON BRIEFLY. AND THAT IS
SOME OF THE NEW PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE ON. A PUT INTO PLACE
SINCE MY DECISION IN MARCH- AND
THAT'S A LITTLE THE LITTLE
REDUCTION IN ENERGY PROGRAM
WHICH I MENTIONED EARLIER WHICH
IS A VOLUNTARY. DEMAND RESPONSE
PROGRAM. AND THE- THIRD PARTY
FOLKS AS- CONNECT CAN CERTAINLY
ARE TAKEN THAT THERE'S A SECOND
IMPORTANT PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN
RECENTLY- UNDERTAKEN BY THE I
AM USING THAT'S CALLED. C. SEPT
WHICH IT. STANDS FOR CALIFORNIA
SECURE ENERGY PROGRAM THAT IS A
PROGRAM THAT IS SET FROM NOW
UNTIL OCTOBER VERY SHORT LIVED.
AND AS I THINK- PRESIDENCY ON
MANGER. EARLIER SOME OF THESE
AND SAY THAT WE HAVE PUT INTO
PLACE THESE TOOLS THAT WE NOW
HAVE WE HOPE WE NEVER HAVE TO
USE FRANKLY. BECAUSE THEY WOULD
BE RIGHT AT THE TIME WHEN I SO
IS SEEN THE MOST STRESS ON TE
GRID AND WHERE WE'RE AT A
TIPPING PLACE SO SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT ARE NOT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
DESIGNED. THAT WOULD WORK FOR-
THE SMALLER SCALE DEMAND
RESPONSE AND ENTITIES THEY ARE
INTENDED FOR LARGE SCALE-
DELIVERABLES IF YOU WELL I'M
I'M NOT SURE IF I ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION I'LL TURN TO ELLIOT IF
YOU WANT TO ADD ANYTHING
FURTHER THANK YOU PRESIDENT I
WOULD JUST ADD YOU KNOW COMING
OUT OF LAST SUMMER WE RECEIVED
A LOT OF INPUT FROM THE
DIMENSIONS COMMUNITY INCLUDING
FROM ALL CONNECTED SOME OF THE
OTHER THIRD PARTY PROVIDERS
THEY DID INDICATE TO US. THAT
THEY FELT THAT OUR OUR BASE
LINING METHODOLOGIES WHERE WERE
UNDERMINING THEIR ABILITY TO.
FULLY DELIVER THE CAPABILITY OF
THEIR RESOURCES SO FOR THIS
SUMMER- WE DID MAKE SOME
CHANGES TO OUR BASELINE
METHODOLOGY WHICH I BELIEVE
HAVE BEEN PRETTY WELL RECEIVED
AND TENDER OPENING UP SOME
ADDITIONAL CAPABILITY AT THE
END OF THE SUMMER WHAT CHANCE
TO LOOK BACK AND SEE WHAT WE
LEARNED ABOUT THAT THE-
EXCHANGE IS WORKING AND IF THEY
ARE SUCCESSFUL TRY TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE. THAT MUCH.
MORE PRODUCT THANKS YEAH IF I
MAY- SENATOR- BECKER THIS IS
STILL GOING TO FROM THE CC I'M
JUST WANT TO ADD AN EXTRA IMAGE
OF THIS MENTIONED- RIGHT AFTER
THE ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS WAS WAS
COMPLETED AND SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE RECEIVED
FROM THE D. R. P.'S- WE WERE
ABLE TO JOINTLY HOLD A COUPLE
OF SOME TABLES TO UNDERSTAND
SPECIFIC ISSUES IN THIS
LIGHTING AND OTHER OTHER TOPICS
AS PERSON MEANS THAT MENTIONED-
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
MODIFICATIONS MADE BY CHRIST SO
HIGH IN THE SHORT TERM- FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT ALSO IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE ICBC HOW
DO YOU SEE ANYTHING IF YOU ARE
WORKING ON IMPROVING THE
BASELINE METHODOLOGIES FOR THE
D. R. PROGRAMS WHICH COULD BE
REFLECTED IN THE UPCOMING YEARS
AND OUR CURRENT WORK IS
EXPECTED TO BE COMPLETED-
SOMEWHERE IN THAT AT THE END OF
MARCH NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND. THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL THEN GO TO CDC GREAT I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL A THAT AND
WORKING ON ELECTRIC JUST BE IN
TOUCH CONTINUE TO EVALUATE OBEY
THE PROBLEM WAS. IN NEST HELLO
ESTIMATING THE BASELINE PRIOR
TO DEMAND REDUCTIONS. BUT IT
DOES SOUND LIKE AND YOUR-
WORKING ON THIS WITH. INITIALLY
FOLKS I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GET REX I THINK THEY CAN BE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE- SOLUTION
HERE. INCENTIVIZE THE RIGHT WAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
OKAY WE'LL CONTINUE TO MOVE ON
WITH THEIR CALENDAR I WANT TO
THANK RESIN BADGER COMMISSIONER
GLINDA AND- PRESIDENT MANGER
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION. I JUST
WANT TO- GIVE A NOTE TO THE
PUBLIC WHO'S LISTENING. WE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT BUT AT THE
END OF TODAY'S HEARING. A
CERTAIN DOLLAR DID YOU HAVE A
COMMENT. CLLR FIND OUT WELL I
JUST YOU KNOW THIS IS THE THEIR
ANNUAL REPORT. AND WE DIDN'T
TALK ABOUT BROADBAND AT ALL AND
ARE WE GONNA HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY AT SOME POINT TO
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO STICK TO
OUR CALENDAR IN ORDER YEAH
THAT'S THE NEXT ITEM OKAY YOU
NEED TO EXERCISE A LITTLE BIT
OF PATIENCE THERE. NOW WE'RE
GONNA AGAIN NOW WE WILL TURN TO
THE CPUC ANNUAL UPDATE AND WE-
WILL HEAR FROM PRESIDENT BADGER
AND WILL KEEP YOU ON THE SET OF
THE PRESENT BETTER IF YOU STAY
ON SO WE CAN HEAR THE ANNUAL
UPDATE TO THE LEGISLATURE HERE
WE GO- PUBLIC SAYING SOMEONE'S.
SENATORS OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND AGAIN MR
VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE. YOU
WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ACTIVITIES OVER THE
PAST YEAR. I AM JOINED BY MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY RACHEL
PETERSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CQC SHE IS ON THE
TELEPHONE- AT EDWARD I THINK
SHE IS ACTUALLY ON SOON TO. AND
ALL WHO IS HERE WITH ME DON'T
EXACTLY OBJECTIVE FOR ENERGY
AND CLIMATE. AND ROB OSBORNE
WILL BE. JOINING US MOMENTARILY
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICATIONS
DIVISION THIS IS AN EVENTFUL
YEAR AND THERE IS MUCH I COULD
TOUCH ON IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WILL FOCUS MY
PRESENTATION ON MATTERS THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO THE STATE AND
THAT CUT ACROSS OUR MISSION TO
ENSURE SAFE. RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE UTILITY SERVICES AS
WE DISCUSSED EARLIER TODAY MUCH
WORK IS SPENT OKAY START MAKING
SURE CALIFORNIANS AGREED THAT
THE STATE AND THAT CAN BE
RELIED UPON. IN THE FACE OF THE
RAPIDLY CHANGING CLIMATE SO I
WILL NOT ADDRESS THAT HERE
THERE IS HOWEVER A STRONG
LINKAGE BETWEEN THE TOPIC AND
THE OTHER IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES
WE ARE UNDERTAKING. WITH
CLIMATE WHILE THE CLAIMANT IS
NOT THE REASON WE ARE FOCUSED
ON MAINTAINING RELIABILITY AND
MEDICATING UTILITY CLASS.
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN
ENSURING CUSTOMERS. HAVE
AFFORDABLE BILLS THAT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY AS A REGULATOR
AND ESSENTIAL UTILITY SERVICES.
HI MY CHANGE IS CREATING A
CRASH THE PRESSURES THAT MAKE
THIS WORK MORE CHALLENGING AND
ALL THE MORE CRITICAL AS WE
TOUCHED ON IN THE EARLIER PART
OF THIS YEAR. WITH THAT IN MIND
TODAY I WILL FOCUS ON ACTIONS
OF CITY YOU SEE HAS TAKEN. OVER
THE PAST YEAR TO ASSIST
FAMILIES DEALING. WITH OPEN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC SO THE
WELFARE APPROACHES TO INCREASE
GRINNED COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK
RESILIENCY DURING EMERGENCY
EVENTS TO DELIVER A RELIABLE
AND CLEAN CRISP OF THE FUTURE
TO ADDRESS INCREASING RATES TO
OVERSEE P. GENIE JUST FRANKLY
OPERATE SAFELY AND BEGIN
IMPLEMENTATION OF A HISTORIC
BROADBAND INVESTMENT HOUSE THIS
SUMMER SO WE WILL INDEED. HAVE
COME OF BROADBAND. WITH THAT I
WILL BEGIN MY PRESENTATION A
LOT YEAR AND A HALF AS PART OF
THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO THE
GROUP IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE
HAVE WORKED WITH. MY FOCUS AND
PURPOSE TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES RECEIVE
SAFE AND RELIABLE UTILITY
SERVICE AS PART OF THIS WORK
THE COMMISSION PLACED
MORATORIUMS ON GAS ELECTRIC
VOICE AND WATER DISCONNECTIONS.
AND DEPLOYED VARIOUS STRATEGIES
TO ENCOURAGE SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO PROVIDE REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS WE ALSO INJURED
MORE PEOPLE WERE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATE RATES
FOR ENERGY I DON'T KNOW HIS
CHARACTER IN THE FAMILY
ELECTRIC RATES DISTANCE THAT
ARE NON HISPANIC. AND LIFELINE
BILL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS TO
HELP REDUCE THE COST OF THESE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES. IN ADDITION
TO SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING APPROPRIATED TO
HELP RELIEVE CUSTOMER UTILITY A
RESURGENCE WE HAVE ALSO
ESTABLISHED INTERIM PROTECTIONS
FOR RESIDENTIAL AND SMALL
BUSINESS CUSTOMERS WHO ARE
BEHIND ON THEIR BILLS AND NEVER
WIRED UTILITIES TO PROVIDE
LONGER ARISING PAYMENT PLANS.
FOR THEIR DRESSING OUT OF A
RESURGENCE WHILE MUCH HAS BEEN
DONE TO PROTECT AND EMPOWER
CUSTOMERS THIS PAST YEAR WE
KNOW MUCH MORE REMAINS AND AS
THE IMPACT OF PANDEMIC OF
CALIFORNIANS LIES YOU BOX WE
WILL CONTINUE TO REVIEW
STRATEGIES TO ASSIST CUSTOMERS.
ON TOP OF THE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA BASED UNPRECEDENTED
WILDFIRE SEASON TWENTY TWENTY
AND ISSUE OR PRETENDS TO BE NO
DIFFERENT WE HAVE ALREADY HAD
OVER SIX THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
FIRE INCIDENTS THAT HAVE BURNED
OVER MILLIONS OF ACRES IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT IS ONLY IN
AUGUST. THE DIXIE FIRE HAS
BURNED OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND ACRES MAKING IT
THE SECOND LARGEST WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY REQUIRED
EVACUATIONS AND MORE THAN SIX
THOUSAND PERSONNEL BEING
MOBILIZED TO COMBAT THE FIRE.
THE MONUMENT MCFARLAND AND
COLOR FIRES HAVE A REACH. EACH
REASONING BURNED WELL OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES THE
CALLER FIRE IS RAGING ACROSS
THIS YEAR. WITH EXPLOSIVE FORCE
THREATENING P. THOSE LINES AND
WELL DENTIST THE CYNICAL AND
THISAND THREATENED NATIVE
WHILE FURTHER SOUTH THE FRENCH
FIVE HAS OUR BURNED OVER C.
THAT ACRE AND MAYBE AN S. AND
G. D. ENERGIZE SOME OF THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE ON AN EMERGENCY
BASIS OUR CHALLENGE OUR
CHANGING CLIMATE HAS
TRANSFORMED A WILDFIRE SEASON.
MAKING IT LONGER AND MORE
INTENSE YOU NEED FOR EXAMPLE
HAS SAID THAT JUST 15% OF ITS
SERVICE TERRITORY WAS IN HIGH
FIRE THREAT. IN TWENTY TWELVE
COMPARED TO TODAY WHERE 50% OF
THE TERRITORY. IS NOW IN HIGH
FIRE DANGER THE FACE OF THE
CLIMATE WE HAVE ENHANCED
REQUIREMENTS FOR UTILITIES
WELFARE MITIGATION PLANNING
INCLUDING IN THEIR EXECUTION OF
PUBLIC SAFETY OUR SHOPS WE HAVE
ALSO TAKEN ACTION TO IMPROVE
THE RESILIENCY OF THE ELECTRIC
WRITTEN COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK
DURING THE QUALIFIERS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHOPS. IN
TERMS OFOUR OVERALL EFFORTS
AND UTILITY WELFARE MITIGATION
WORK HAS BEEN AND THAT WORK HAS
BEEN DONE AT THE CBC THROUGH
THE OVERSIGHT OF THE UTILITIES
WELFARE MITIGATION PLANS BY THE
WILDFIRE SAFETY DIVISION WHICH
PURSUANT TO STATUTE. TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY THIS
PAST JULY AND BECAME THE OFFICE
OF ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY
THE OPPOSITE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY SETS THE
GUIDELINES EVALUATES APPROVES
ENSURES COMPLIANCE. UTILITIES
WATER MITIGATION PLANS ON THE
WHOLE HOWEVER THE LAUGHTER
EDUCATION PLANS ARE JUST THAT
THEY ARE PLANTS. TRUE REDUCTION
IN RISK WILL COME FROM THE
EXECUTION OF THESE PLANTS IN
THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAYING HE IS A
STATUS EXTENSIVE COMPLIANCE
OVERSIGHT AROUND
IMPLEMENTATION. MOVIE NOT TO P.
S. P. S. IMPROVEMENTS AMONG THE
UTILITIES MANY WILDFIRE
MITIGATION TOOLS IS A PROACTIVE
SHUTTING OFF POWER TO CUSTOMERS
DURING HIGH RISK SITUATIONS
JUGGLING THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
NOT ANYTHING WHILE HIGHER. WELL
THE UTILITIES MAY USE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF AS A
WILDFIRE MITIGATION TOOL OUR
MESSAGE TO THEM HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT AND HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR. OUR SAFETY POUT HAVEN'T
HELPED SKEWS ME PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHOPS MUST BE A MEASURE
OF LAST RESORT. IN THE LATTER
WELL CLARIFICATION AND EACH
YEAR THEY MUST WORK TO REDUCE
THE SCOPE THE GENERATION. AND
THE FREQUENCY OF THESE EVENTS
AS YOU ALL KNOW VERY WELL
SHUTTING OUT POWER TO WEIGHT K.
WELL VERY REACH ME DISTRESS FOR
THE AND CREATE CAN C. SAFETY
SINCE TWENTY NINETY WE HAVE A
JOB TO OF UP AND THEN TO POWER
OF GUIDELINES TO DRIVE THE
UTILITIES TO IMPROVE THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS AND COORDINATION
WE HAVE IMPACTED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TRIBES AND BILLABLE
CUSTOMERS AND SHE TAKE
APPROACHES THAT REDUCE THE
SCOPE AND THE FREQUENCY AND
DURATION OF THE OUTAGES ALL OUR
GUIDELINES HAVE BEEN HEAVILY
INFORMED I STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK
AND INVOLVEMENT. IN REGIME PUT
MANY CUSTOMER ADVOCATES AND
ADVOCACY GROUPS HAS HELPED
PROVIDE A CLEAR VIEW ABOUT THE
P. S. P. S. EVENTS AND HOW THEY
ARE IMPACTING CUSTOMERS AND HOW
TO MINIMIZE THAT IMPACT
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO THE
MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR STATE.
WE HAVE ALSO BEEN VERY FOCUSED
ON ENSURING COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS ARE CONVENIENTLY
LOCATED IMPROVING HOW THEY
IDENTIFY AND COMMUNICATE WITH
MEDICALLY VULNERABLE CUSTOMERS
AND SPEEDING UP AND EXPANDING
THEIR BACKUP BATTERY PROGRAMS
TO SUPPORT THESE CUSTOMERS THE
MEDICALLY BASED MEDICAL
BASELINE CUSTOMERS DURING A P.
S. P. S. S. SINCE THE
DISASTROUS. OUR SHOPS OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THE TELEVISA MADE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWENTY TWENTY WELL THE NUMBER
PS PS OF THIS ONE UP. THE
NUMBER OF CUSTOMER OUTAGES.
HOURS WENT DOWN HOWEVER I MEAN.
THERE STILL REMAINS SIGNIFICANT
AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW CRITICAL
IT IS FOR CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO COMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES DURING THESE EVENTS WE
HAVE ALSO ISSUED A REQUIREMENT
FOR COMMUNICATION PROVIDERS TO
INSTALL SEVENTY TWO HOUR POWER
BACK UP. TO ENSURE THE
PROVISION OF ESSENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICES AND
POWER SHUT OFF THIS. EDISON AND
PG&E HAVE ALREADY CALLED PS
PETER IT'S EVENTS THIS YEAR AND
BE BEING IN THE MIDST OF AN
ALREADY DIFFICULT WHILE WHILE
HER SEASON WE'RE EXPECTING TO
SEE THEM SADLY CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE THIS APPROACH. AS YOU
MOVE INTO THE WILDFIRE SEASON
AND BEYOND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
SPURRING CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
AND UTILITIES EXECUTION OF PSP
SO THAT'S REDUCING IMPACTS ON
THEIR CUSTOMERS. AND THESE
EVENTS HAVE BOLSTERED SEVEN
POSTED BY OUR ONGOING
PARTNERSHIP WITH HALLOWEEN. S.
AND CALCULATOR DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY ESPECIALLY THOSE CAN BE
INTO THE MICRO GETS HELP ALSO
RECEIVED ATTENTION IN THE
EFFORT TO MITIGATE RISK AND
IMPROVE RESILIENCY THERE ARE
SEVERAL AVAILABLE STRATEGIES TO
MITIGATE PUBLIC SAFETY SHUT OFF
IMPACTS AND CAN PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN PROVIDING
ELECTRIC RESILIENCY IN CERTAIN
INSTANCES WE JUST QUICK ACTION
LAST YEAR IN ADVANCE OF THE
LAST WELFARE SEASON TO
ACCELERATE DEPLOYMENT OF
MIGRANTS RESILIENCY INCLUDING
STREAMLINING ASPECTS OF THE
INTERCONNECTION PROCESS.
MODERNIZING TERRACE TO MAXIMIZE
RESILIENCY BENEFITS REQUIRING
UTILITIES TO IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY AND COLLABORATION
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS IN MAY IN
MATTERS RELATED TO RESILIENCY
PLANNING AND CREATING AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM HER NOVEL AND
CLEAN COMMUNITY RECORDS AND
RESOURCE NUMBER WHILE MUCH
FOCUS HAS JUSTIFIABLY BEEN
PLACED ON NEAR TERM GREATER
LIABILITY AND RESILIENCY THE
CQC HAS ALSO CONTINUED OUR
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION FOR
THE STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE. THAT WORK HAS BEEN
MOVING FORWARD AND WILL ONLY
ACCELERATE IN THE MONTHS AND
YEARS TO COME. OVER THE MEDIUM
AND LONGER TERM CD THE CITY
CEBU CITY MUST ENSURE THAT ALL
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES UNDER OUR
JURISDICTION OUR PROCUREMENT
FOR CARING ENOUGH RESOURCES. TO
MEET INCREASED DEMAND FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS AND INCREASED
ELECTRIFICATION OUR
TRANSPORTATION AND BUILDING
SECTORS THOSE RESOURCES MUST BE
UNVEILED TO MEET DEMAND AT ALL
HOURS INCLUDING THE SUMMER
EVENING HOURS AS JULIE
GENERATION IS DECREASING. AT A
FASTER RATE THAN ELECTRICITY
IS. THAT WHAT YOUR CITY DEMAND
THE CDC MUST ENSURE THAT THESE
NEW RESOURCES THEMSELVES
SUPPORT OUR AMBITIOUS AND
NECESSARY CLINICAL TO MEET THE
STATE'S FUTURE LIABILITY AND
DECARBONISATION NEEDS THIS
SPRING WE ORDERED AT ELEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED MEGAWATT
INCREASE IN PROCUREMENT OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS AS PART OF
OUR INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING PROCEEDING THIS IS THE
LARGEST AMOUNT OF CLEAN ENERGY
CAPACITY EVER DIRECTED BY THE
COMMISSION IN A SINGLE
PROCUREMENT ORDER. ELEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
IS IN ADDITION TO THE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF NEW
NET WELL THINK OF PASSING CLEAN
ENERGY RESOURCES THAT WILL COME
ONLINE BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY
AND TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AS A
RESULT OF PRIOR CPUC ACTIONS.
THIS INCLUDES WILL WIND SOLAR
BATTERY STORAGE AND SOLAR PLUS
STORAGE WELL THE PURPOSE OF THE
NEW BECOME IS PRIMARILY
RELIABILITY TO REPLACE THE
RETIREMENT OF DIAVEL CANYON AND
THE ONCE THROUGH COOLING UNITS
THAT ARGUMENT ALSO SUPPORTS OUR
STATE'S LONG TERM GREEN CAP
GREENHOUSE. GAS EMISSION GOALS
WITH WITH REGARD TO THE
REPLACEMENT OF THE APPLE CANYON
WE WILL REQUIRE AT LEAST TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
FOR TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THAT COMES
FROM THE FIRM ZERO EMISSION
RESOURCES THIS IS IN ADDITION
TO THE LARGE. AMOUNT OF ZERO
EMISSION PROCUREMENTS THAT HAS
ALREADY TAKEN PLACE OVER THE
PAST YEARS IN ANTICIPATION OF
DIABOLOS RETIREMENT LOOKING
AHEAD THE COMMISSION IS
EVALUATING AND STRONGLY
INCLINED TO A JOB IN A DECISION
LATER THIS YEAR A MORE
AGGRESSIVE THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
METRIC TONS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS TARGETS. IN THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR BY TWENTY
THIRTY ONE FURTHER ACCELERATING
OUR PATH TO A ZERO CARBON
ELECTRIC SYSTEM LET ME CATCH ON
RATES VERY QUICKLY UNDERMINE
EVERYTHING I'VE DISCUSSED SO
FAR IS THAT ALL OF THESE
INCENTIVES COME WITH COSTS
CALIFORNIA UTILITIES ARE
CONFRONTING MULTIPLE FACTORS
THAT ARE PLACING UPWARD
PRESSURES ON ELECTRIC GRATES
PRESSURES THAT ARE EXACERBATED
BY A CHANGING CLIMATE. OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS RATES ARE
EXPECTED TO EXCEED INFLATION
AND INCREASED FOR THE AVERAGE
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMER BY THREE
POINT 5% TO FOUR POINT 5% PER
YEAR THIS AMOUNTS TO AROUND AN
AVERAGE MONTHLY BILL INCREASE
OVER THE COURSE OF TEN YEARS
OVER THE COURSE OF TEN YEARS.
OF FORTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR PG&E
CUSTOMERS. THIRTY EIGHT DOLLARS
RECEIPT FOR EDISON CUSTOMERS.
AND. SIXTY SEVEN FOR SDG AND E.
CUSTOMERS THERE ARE VARIOUS
REASONS FOR THESE PRODUCT
PROJECTED INCREASES IN ELECTRIC
RATES AS I MENTIONED IN EARLIER
TESTIMONY WHILE HIGH MEDICATION
COSTS BEING A SIGNIFICANT COST
DRIVER TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION COSTS WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW TO MEET DEMAND
AND INTEGRATE CLEAN ENERGY
RESOURCES INTO OUR DECLINING
ELECTRICITY SALES DUE TO THE
GROWTH OF DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES. WILL RAISE ELECTRIC
RATES FOR CUSTOMERS WHO DO NOT
HAVE THEM ON THEIR PROPERTIES.
WE HELD THE NANBAN IN FEBRUARY
THIS YEAR TO DISCUSS AND
EXPLORE WAYS TO ADDRESS THESE
RATE PRESSURES AND EQUITY
CONCERNS MANY INTERESTING
CONCEPTS WERE PROVIDED AND
WE'RE USING THE IDEAS
GENERATED. AT THAT ENVELOPE TO
INFORM OUR APPROACH GOING
FORWARD AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
WE HAVE ACTED TO ENSURE
CUSTOMERS DO NOT HAVE THEIR
UTILITY SERVICES TURNED OFF AT
WORK WORKABLE PAYMENT PLANS AND
HAVE MUCH. AND HAVE PUSHED
UTILITIES TO INCREASE AWARENESS
AND ENROLLMENT IN BILL
REDUCTION PROGRAMS LIKE
CHARACTER. IS AND LIFELINE IN
ADDITION. WE'RE LOOKING AT
LONGER SOLUTIONS UNDER TERMS OF
TO OUR PORTABILITY PROCEEDING
WHICH IS EXAMINING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF POLICIES TO
ADDRESS RATE CONCERNED AND
LOOKING AT ISSUES LIKE REGIONAL
COST IN DEVELOPING APPROACHES
THAT WOULD ENABLE US TO
MEASURE. RACE AND RATE
DISCOUNTS. ARE BASED ON
AFFORDABILITY TO INDIVIDUAL
HOUSEHOLDS. I WANT YOU VERY
QUICKLY RUN THROUGH P. GINNY
SAFETY OVERSIGHT AND THAT WE
WILL GET TO BRUSH OUR BROADBAND
PACKAGE. I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON CBC'S OVERSIGHT OF
PG&E FOLLOWING ITS EXIT FROM
BANKRUPTCY AND ITS
RESPONSIBILITY TO OPERATE A
SYSTEM SAFELY AND IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF ITS CUSTOMERS. AS A
CONDITION OF P. GINNY'S EXIT
FROM BANKRUPTCY WE IMPOSE
VARIOUS REQUIREMENTS INTENDED
TO DRIVE P. JEANNIE OPERATE.
MORE SAFELY AND TO PROVIDE CBC
WITH ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO HOLD
P. GINNY ACCOUNTABLE FOR MAKING
PROGRESS IN THIS REGARD
INCLUDING AMONG THESE TOOLS IS
A CREATION OF A SIX STEP
ENHANCED OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS AS WELL AS
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF AN
INDEPENDENT SAFETY MONITOR. WHO
REPORT DIRECTLY TO THIS
COMMISSION IN THIS PAST YEAR WE
UTILIZED THIS EXCEPT PROCESS
PLACING P. JANICE ONE OF THE
PROCESS AND REQUIRING
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS FOR ITS
FAILURE TO SUFFICIENTLY
PRIORITIZED EDUCATION
CLEARANCES CURRENTS AND POWER
LINES BASED ON WRIST. OUR STAFF
IS OVERSEEING AND REVIEWING P.
GENIES PROGRESS IN MEETING THE
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS WE HAVE
IMPOSED. WE ALSO OPERATES A
SAFETY POLICY DIVISION THE
SAFETY POLICY DIVISION TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH COMPETITIVE
SOLICITATION OR AN INDEPENDENT
SAFETY MONITOR WE WILL COME ON
BOARD NEXT YEAR I HOPE AS EARLY
AS JANUARY AND WILL REPORT TO
THE COMMISSION TO AUGMENT OUR
OVERSIGHT OF P. GENIES
EXECUTION OF REAL TIME
OPERATIONS TO ENSURE. THE
UTILITY IS FOCUSED ON LONG TERM
OUTCOMES THAT PROMOTE THE
SAFETY AND RELIABILITY. AS WE
CONTINUE TO BE FOCUSED ON
HOLDING PG&E ACCOUNTABLE FOR
OPERATING SAFELY LAST WEEK I
SENT A LETTER G. P. GINNY
HAVING POPPY NOTIFYING HER THAT
I HAVE REQUESTED CPUC STAFF TO
CONDUCT FACT FINDING A RANDOM
PATTERN OF SELF REPORTED MISSED
INSPECTIONS AND OTHER SELF
REPORTED SAFETY INCIDENTS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER A
RECOMMENDATION TO ADVANCE P.
JEANNIE FURTHER. WITHIN THE
ENHANCED OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS IS
WARRANTED AS I COMMUNICATED TO
MISS POPPY SEED UC I HOLD
CUSTOMER SAFETY AS A TOP
PRIORITY AND EXPECT LEADERSHIP
FROM THE P. JEANNIE TO EXECUTE
ON ITS SAFETY RESPONSIBILITIES
THIS IS A MESSAGE P. JEANNIE
HAS HER CARESSED MORE TIMES
THAN I SHOULD HAVE TO EXPLAIN
AND REPEAT. WHAT PG&E IS UNABLE
TO DO THIS ON ITS OWN WE HAVE
USED AND WILL CONTINUE TO USE
THE TOOLS AND AUTHORITY AT OUR
DISPOSAL. TO HOLD PG&E
ACCOUNTABLE NOW WILLING TO.
PACKAGE FILING I WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE WORK WE HAVE
STARTED TO IMPLEMENT THE
HISTORIC SIX BILLION DOLLAR
BROADBAND INVESTMENT WHICH
INCLUDES THREE POINT TWO
BILLION FOR A STATE WIDE OPEN
ACCESS MIDDLE MILE NETWORK TO
BILLION IN THE IN AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN FUNDS FOR A GRANT
PROGRAM. THE LAST MILE
CONNECTIONS TO UNDERSERVED
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE. SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FROM NEW
LOAN LOSS RESERVE FUND THAT
WILL SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT ISSUE BONDS TO BUILD THEIR
OWN BROADBAND NETWORKS AND
FUNDS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS.
REACTS REFORMS TO THE PUBLIC
HOUSING THE CAMERA AND THE
UPDATES THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCE
SERVICES VIA I AM VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE SINGLE LARGEST STATE
INVESTMENT IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY BUT WE HAVE MUCH TO DO
AND THE COMMISSION TO DEPLOY
THESE FUNDS AND TRULY. BRING
BROADBAND SERVICES TO THOSE
MOST IN NEED WE HAVE ALREADY
TAKEN THE FIRST STEPS TO
IMPLEMENT THESE PROVISIONS WE
ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY FINANCE AND
TRANSPORTATION TO SET UP AN
INTER AGENCY AGREEMENTS AND
RECEIVE NECESSARY RESOURCE. WE
CAN'T STOP THE NINETY DAY
PUBLIC COMMENT PROCESS REQUIRED
FOR THE MIDDLE MILE NETWORK WE
ARE ALSO ENGAGING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DISCUSS HOW
THESE INVESTMENTS CAN TRANSFORM
BROADBAND SERVICES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THE FIRST MEETING
OF THE MIDDLE MILE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WAS HELD LAST WEEK.
AND WE WOULD LOOK AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PROVIDING UPDATES TO
YOU AS WE MAKE PROGRESS IN OUR
JOINT AGENCY IMPLEMENTATION AND
FINALLY WE WILL BEGIN THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PROCESS FOR THE
LAST MILE. AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE GRANT. PROGRAMS IN
THE COMING WEEK SO MISTER JERRY
AND MR CHAIRMAN WITH THE IDEA
YOU FOR THE IMAGE TO SPEAK YOU
TODAY AND TO ALLOW ME TO
ADDRESS SOME OF WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN DOING IN THIS LAST YEAR
YEAR AND A HALF- FOR THE
CRITICAL ISSUES. TO ADDRESS THE
CRITICAL ISSUESTHAT THE CVC IS
FACED WITH. AND WITH THAT
MYSELF AND MY CLUB COLLEAGUES
WILL BE HONORED TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AND I'M PARTICULARLY-
GRATEFUL FOR YOU- AT LEAST-
HIGHLIGHTING THAT YOU DID ONLY
MENTIONS SOME. OF THE THINGS WE
DID THIS YEAR AND IN REVIEWING
THE- TWENTY TWENTY ANNUAL
REPORT I'M ALWAYS JUST
IMPRESSED BY. THE IMMENSE
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION THAT'S
PUT TOGETHER INTO THIS REPORT
AND PART CHECK YOUR LEAD TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE WAS JUST SO
MUCH WORK DONE THIS YEAR. IN SO
MANY DIVERSE AREAS YOU CAN
REALLY LOOK AT THIS REPORT NINE
COURAGE TO PUBLISH TO REVIEW IT
IT'S AVAILABLE ONLINE. AND IT
SPEAKS. TO US SO MANY THINGS AT
THE CPUC IS WORKING ON IN
PARTICULAR SO IT'S- IT'S JUST
SO ENORMOUS WORKLOAD EVERY YEAR
AND I'M ALWAYS PLEASED TO PAGE
THROUGH IT DOESN'T REALLY LOOK
AT HOW FAST PC WORKS EVERY YEAR
AT IMPLEMENTING. STATE LAWS AND
DIFFERENT POLICIES AND HOW.
EVEN INDEPENDENTLY LIKE THIS
YEAR THEY UNDERTOOK. THE
CULTURAL SENSITIVITY TRAINING
OF STAFF IN LIEU OF THE GEORGE
FLOYD INCIDENT. HERE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THERE WAS ALSO SOME SENSITIVITY
TO THAT ISSUE- AND MANY MANY
MORE SO I APPRECIATE THE REPORT
I APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION.
IN PARTICULAR I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE PROGRESS ON
IMPLEMENTING SP FOURTEEN FORTY-
THE N. S. P. FORTY FORTY
LEGISLATION. TO ESTABLISH A
RENEWABLE CLASS GAS STANDARD AS
I PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE
PLEASE THE STAFF REPORT. THAT
WAS ISSUED A FEW MONTHS AGO ON
THE SUBJECT- I'D I'D LIKE TO
ASK- CAN YOU GIVE ME SOME KIND
OF AN IDEA OF WHEN WE CAN
EXPECT THIS THE PC TO ADOPT THE
FINAL DECISION. ON THE DROP
STAFF REPORT- IT WILL IT BE
BEFORE THE- END OF THE YEAR-
JUST IN LOOKING AT THAT REPORT
AND THEN SEEMED- THE NUMBERS
BASED ON THE NUMBERS I'VE SEEN.
IF THE PSC ADOPTS THE STAFF
PROPOSAL AS PROPOSED. WE CAN
REDUCE REDUCE GHGS BY ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION METRIC TONS TONS
PER YEAR WHICH IS THE
EQUIVALENT OF TAKING FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND CARS OFF THE
ROAD THAT IS AN AMAZING
STATISTIC AND I'M JUST SO EAGER
TO SEE THAT POLICY BUT PUT IT
BE PUT INTO PLACE. IS THERE ANY
IDEA WHEN THAT CAN BE- MAN
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION GOVERNOR. SENATOR
MISTER CHAIRMAN- WE I HOPE YOU
HAVE A P. D. L. BY THE END OF
THE YEAR. THAT WILL ADDRESS
YOUR FIRST QUESTION AND IN
TERMS OF THE MOVING DATE- MM
TWO USED TO THIRTY EIGHT- SOON
ADD THAT TO MAYBE EVEN BEFORE
THE END OF THE YEAR. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALSO ON BROADBAND
APPRECIATE YOUR ENTHUSIASTIC.
EMBRACING OF OUR ACTIONS HERE
ON THE SIX BILLION AND STUFF OF
COURSE. AS I SPEAK TO PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY AND AS WE ARE
CONTINUING OUR. DISCUSSIONS ON
THIS I MEAN WE THE **** THAT WE
HAVE EVEN FINISHED ALL THE WORK
ON THIS LEGISLATION WE'RE STILL
WE MOVE SO MIGHT MAKE SOME
CHANGES BUT I APPRECIATE. THAT
THE SUPER CPUC HAS ALREADY
TAKEN THE SONG IT'S ALREADY
STARTING TO WORK ON IT THE
NUMBER ONE QUESTION. I AM GET-
GETTING ON THIS IS- WHEN. WHEN
WILL WHEN WILL THE CPU IT SEE
EXPECT TO COMPLETE THE PROCESS
OF IDENTIFYING THE LOCATIONS
FOR. MIDDLE MILE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S SOMETHING IT'S- ASKED-
QUITE A BIT I KNOW IT'S A
LITTLE EARLY BUT AT THE SAME
TIME- THIS IS- CPUC. ALREADY
HAVE A PROJECTION OF WHAT COULD
THAT COULD BE COMPLETED MISTER
CHAIR AND BEFORE I ANSWER THAT
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU- FOR
NOTING THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
THE CPC DOES AN IMPORTANT. WORK
THAT IS ILLUSTRATED IN THE
ANNUAL STAFF WILL BE DELIGHTED.
THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN STARTING THANK YOU I'M
TURNING. TO ROB OSBORNE WHO IS
OUR DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICATIONS
HE HAS BEEN DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
OUR BROADBAND EFFORTS. AND RON
YOU CAN PROBABLY BEST ANSWER
THAT QUESTION ON ON THE
LOCATION OF THE MIDDLE MILE.
YES SENATOR. THANK YOU SURE WAY
SO. THE MIDDLE MILE LOCATIONS-
WE HAVE SET OUT FOR PUBLIC
ALREADY. AND WE HAVE A NINETY
DAYS TO GET PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THOSE LOCATIONS AND WILL BE
PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION TO
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY. WITHIN
THAT TIME FRAME SO THAT WOULD
BE DAY FROM TWO WEEKS AGO RIGHT
SO WE'RE SHOOTING FOR I THINK
OCTOBER EIGHTEENTH OKAY AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU WILL BE MAKING
THE ULTIMATE DECISION ABOUT
THAT ALIGNMENT IS AND- WE HAVE
A THIRTY A NINETY DAY PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION INPUT PROCESS
WHAT IS THE FINAL. THE
DELIVERING PROFITS CAN LOOK
LIKE SO WE HAVE IT OUT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT NOW AND
ONCE WE RECEIVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THEN WE HAVE REPLY
COMMENT PERIOD- AND ALL THAT
HAS TO TRANSPIRE BEFORE THE
OCTOBER EIGHTEENTH DEADLINE.
AND SO THIS MIDDLE MILE LIST OF
LOCATIONS WILL PROVIDE AS PART
OF THE TECHNOLOGY AND THAT IS
DONE IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
CPA. SO IT'S NOT SOLELY THE
PUC'S INCORPORATING PUBLIC
COMMENTS AS WELL AS WORKING
WITH DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
AND THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR OKAY VERY WELL
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH. ON
THE LAST SUBJECT I WANTED TO
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR WORKING SO.
COLLABORATIVELY AND RESPONSIBLY
WITH MY OFFICE ON ON. THE PHONE
NUMBER IF THEY HAVE ISSUES AND
IN PARTICULAR. RELATED TO THE
INTERVENOR COMPENSATION
PROGRAM. I REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR- WORKING WITH US ON
THIS- OF COURSE YOU KNOW WE-
YOU KNOW THE- THE INTERVENORS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT PROCESS.
KEEPING OUR RATES LOW. AND SO-
YOU KNOW I SUPPORT THAT PROCESS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HEAR THE
DIVERSE. VOICES PARTICIPATING
IN THE CPUC PROCEEDINGS OF
COURSES ORGANIZATIONS OF SAY IT
SAVED RATEPAYERS. MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR-
DIRECTING ADDITIONAL STAFF
RESOURCES TOWARD RESOLVING THE
BACKLOG OF. OF INTERVENOR
COMPENSATION REIMBURSEMENT SO
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE LETTER
THAT I RECEIVED AND- AND YOUR
INTEREST IN THE INTERVIEW-
COMPENSATION WHICH IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT. AND YES INDEED WE
DID ADMINISTRATIVELY ADD TO
EMPLOYEES IN JULY TO HELP
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE STAKEHOLDERS BUT I DON'T
WANT TO LEAVE IT JUST THERE I'M
I'M REVIEWING THE PROCESS IS
WITHIN THE INTERVENOR COMMONS
COM AREA TO SEE IF WE CAN
IMPROVE UPON. THE PROCESSES
THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE I'M SURE
THE EMPLOYEES HAVE- THE NEXT
MATCH BETTER IDEAS THAN I ON
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE. THEIR THEIR
SITUATION SO THEY CAN MAKE
DECISIONS MORE QUICKLY AND WE
WILL BE LOOKING TO SEE WHETHER
INDEED WE NEED TO. WE WILL WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION I'M
DOING SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR LETTER I GREATLY
APPRECIATED IT AND FOR YOUR
INTEREST AND I SHARE YOUR
INTERESTS AND I SHARE SOME OF
THE CONCERNS ON THE BACK SO WE
HAVE I MENTIONED IT. WAS ONCE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT- IN OUR
COMMISSION MEETINGS THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL GO
TOWARD VICE CHAIR. CENTER
DOLLAR FOLLOWED BY A CENTRAL
BANKER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO ALSO JUST
RECOGNIZE THAT- YOU'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB WITH OF ATTEMPTING TO
TRACK P. JEANNIE ON THEIR
PROGRESS I'VE ALSO DONE THAT
MYSELF AND OUT IN THE DISTRICT-
MAKE CHECKING UP ON THEM IN
THEIR LINES AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
MILES OF LINE AND- AND IT'S A-
TALL ORDER SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND- AND I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
CONTINUING TO. HAVE A THIRD
PARTY VALIDATORS WHICH I THINK
IS VERY IMPORTANT- FOR THOSE OF
US WHO ARE. BATTLING WILDFIRES
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY SUMMER DUE
TO SOME SORT OF INTERACTION
WITH- UTILITY PROVIDERS OF
ENERGY SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND I DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ON BROADBAND AND I
KNOW THAT WE PASSED. THE SP ONE
FIFTY SIX- IT IS AN AWESOME
PIECE OF LEGISLATION A LOT OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE THE TRAILER
BILL IMPLEMENTING THE GOVERNOR
SIX BILLION BAHT PER PLANT
BROAD. BAND PLAN. IS INTENDED
TO FUND BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL WILL
FINALLY CONNECT CALIFORNIA'S
REMAINING UNSERVED. COMMUNITIES
THAT WILL HAPPEN. THAT HAVE NO
OR VERY SLOW BROADBAND SERVICE
WHICH ARE MOSTLY IN HIGH FIRE
THREAT AREAS SP ONE FIFTY SIX
ESTABLISHED. CALIFORNIA'S NEW
UNSER STANDARD AS HAVING NO
PROVIDER OFFERING LAST MILE
SERVICE AT A- SPEED OF AT LEAST
TWENTY FIVE. MEGABYTES PER
SECOND DOWNSTREAM AND THREE
MEGABYTES PER SECOND UPSTREAM
DESPITE SP ONE FIFTY SIX
CODIFYING A TWENTY FIVE THREE
ANSWER STANDARD THE CPUC IS
ALREADY USING A DIFFERENT
STANDARD THE CPUC EARLY IN
AUGUST IMPLEMENTED SP ONE FIFTY
SIX AND THE STANDARD IS A
HUNDRED DOWN WHICH DOES NOT
FOLLOW SP ONE FIFTY SIX AND
DOES NOT TARGET THE SIX
BILLION. TO FINALLY CONNECT
CALIFORNIA'S HARDEST TO REACH
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE ALSO IN
HIGH FIRE DANGER DISTRICTS
AREAS SO I WAS MY QUESTION IS
WHY WOULD YOU CHANGE IT FROM.
WHICH THE STATUTE SAYS TWENTY
FIVE THREE TO A HUNDRED DOWN WE
CAN ANSWER THAT- MISTER VICE
CHAIR WE CONCERNED ALWAYS ABOUT
PROVIDING THE BEST SERVICES TO
THE CUSTOMER SO THEY ARE SAFE
IN WILDFIRE AREAS AND THAT THEY
CAN COMMUNICATE- SAFELY BOTH
WAYS AND- AND OTHER TYPE OF
BRUNCH PRIVATE ACTIVITIES SO I
MEAN IN TERMS OF BROAD ROB OUR
SPORT. FOR A EXPLANATION ANSWER
YOUR SPECIFIC QUESTION SIR
THANK YOU. RON YES THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR- THE QUICK ANSWER IS
WE HAVE NOT CHANGED THE
STANDARD THAT WILL BE USING FOR
THE LAST MILE FUNDING IT WILL
BE TWENTY FIVE THREE AND FILING
THE FEDERAL GUIDELINES AS WELL
AS SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY SIX IT
IS TWENTY FIVE THREE- I THINK
THE CONFUSION CAME UP WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT USING A HUNDRED DOWN
AS A STARTING POINT FOR THE
MIDDLE MILE. DESIGNATIONS WHICH
WHICH CENSUS DESIGNATED PLACES
WOULD BE CONNECTED THE SAME
LOCATIONS APPEAR IN THE TWENTY
FIVE THREE MAP AS WELL AND
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO UPDATE THE
MAP WITH THE LOCATION. SO THE
BOTTOM LIE IS THERE'S NO
CHANGE IN TERMS OF THE MIDDLE
MILE LOCATIONS- WHETHER. YOU
DOING TWENTY FIVE THREE OR A
HUNDRED DOWN TELL WHAT IT MEANS
THAT THE WHO ARE I DID MY GOAL
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO
HAVE NO AND I THINK WE'RE
TALKING THE SAME THING IS MAYBE
NOT MAYBE I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING
BUT MAKE SURE THAT. THE
UNDERSERVED OR NOT SERVED OUR
FIRST IN EVEN THE MIDDLE MILE
OR THE LAST MILE THAT'S CORRECT
PERFECT THANK YOU OKAY I HAVE
ONE LAST QUESTION ON BROADBAND
MISTER CHAIR THANKS FOR
INDULGING ME I'VE BEEN VERY
CRITICAL OF THE CAST OF RUNNING
WHICH I- WAS A JOINT AUTHOR ON
SIX TWENTY SIX SIXTY FIVE. AND
I ALSO- HAVE SO THERE'S BEEN
SIX HUNDRED AND- I THINK THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS SPENT ON
THE CAST OF FUNDS AND I HAD MY
STAFF GO THROUGH AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW MANY HOUSEHOLDS.
WERE HOOKED UP SO I JUST I'M
I'M GONNA ASK A QUESTION HERE
I'M ASSUMING WELL I COULDN'T
FIND IT ON YOUR WEBSITE NEITHER
COULD MY STAFF. OF AN ENERGY I
JUST PICKED A PROJECT SO I HAVE
ONE HERE IT'S THE- IT'S A THE-
IT'S TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR TWENTY SEVEN ALMOST
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
FOR RACE GIGA FI. FEELIN
PROJECT. TO GIVE GUY FEELING
PROJECT WAS IS. WAS WILL
INSTALL FIBER. TO THE PREMISES-
WITH CASTS OF FUNDS TO PRIOR
YEARS UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
IN SAMBAR DINO COUNTY. WITH ITS
IT I HAVE THE RESOLUTION NUMBER
WHICH IS. T. DASH ONE SEVEN
FIVE TWO. OPT OUT OF THAT
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
KNOW WHERE COULD I FIND OUT HOW
MANY HOMES ARE ACTUALLY HOOKED
UP AND IN ALL THE PROJECTS LILY
HUNDREDS OF THEM. I WAS NOT
ABLE TO. FIGURE OUT HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE BEING HOOKED UP AND
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING. FROM
LISA SHARED ON YOUR WEBSITE. SO
THAT. THOSE OF US WHO ARE. ARE
ADVOCATING FOR THESE FUNDS
ENTER AND CONTRACT TO SEE- HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING HOOKED UP- WHAT ELSE
WOULD I FIND. MR VICE CHAIR
EXCELLENT COOL CONCERN AND- I
TAKE IT WELL THAT IT SHOULD BE
PROBABLY BETTER- DIGITALIZED ON
OUR WEBSITE AND BOTH MR OSBORNE
AND I WILL TAKE THAT BUT I
WANTED TO INTERRUPT. FOR A MORE
SPECIFIC ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION YES THANK YOU MIKE
MISTER RIGHT SURE THAT IS A
GREAT QUESTION AND YOU'RE
CORRECT IT'S NOT INCLUDED IN
THE ANNUAL REPORT THAT
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD PROVIDE
YOU- AS WELL AS WE COULD ALSO.
CONSIDER INCLUDING THAT IN THE
NEXT IN THE REPORT- I DON'T.
HAVE ANY INFORMATION FROM THE
PROVIDER SO THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S READILY
AVAILABLE SO OUT OF THE SO IT
DID DO YOU HAVE A NUMBER CAN
YOU TELL ME OUT OF THE SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
SPENT IN KASA FUNDS HOW MANY
PEOPLE ACTUALLY BEING CONNECTED
NOT JUST COMMUNITIES THAT IT
SERVES TO BUT ACTUALLY PEOPLE
THAT ARE HOOKED UP YES SO WE
COLLECT THAT THAT INFORMATION
OVER A PERIOD OF AT LEAST THREE
YEARS AFTER PROJECT COMPLETION
AND BEYOND THAT. WE'RE NOT
COLLECTING SO WE CAN PROVIDE
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE UP TO
THAT POINT AWESOME I WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE THAT. OKAY VERY WELL
GOOD QUESTIONS CENTERED ALI
SENATOR BAKER AND IT WILL GO TO
CENTRE BRADFORD THANK YOU CLICK
HERE I'D LIKE TO- FIRST START
WITH SOME THANK YOUS HAVE OF MY
OWN AND- WHEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
THE THIRTY EIGHT. MM T. TARGET
THAT'S TREMENDOUS NEWS CENTER
REALLY BUT TERRIFIC TO HEAR
THANK YOU ALSO ELEVEN HALF
MEGAWATTS OF. NEW CAPACITY AND
FOR THE OTHER COMMISSIONERS
HERE TEAMS TIMELY RESPONSE TO
OUR LETTER ABOUT DIABLO CANYON
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE DON'T.
REPLACE THAT- WE DO REPLACE IT
WITH A CLEAN ENERGY RESOURCES
AND MAKING SURE THAT TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OR FROM
ZERO EMITTING SOURCES. THAT
ARE- AVAILABLE DURING SPECIFIC
SPECIFIED PEAK LOAD HOURS I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT
ALSO FOR PUTTING P. G. AGENCY
ON NOTICE- YOU MENTIONED HERE
TODAY. ON A POTENTIAL ENHANCED
OVERSIGHT GIVEN WHAT HAS
HAPPENED YET AGAIN BUT MY
QUESTION WOULD BE- YOU KNOW YOU
ARE PROVING ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF
MONEY FOR WILDFIRE. PREVENTION
ALMOST FIFTEEN BILLION FOR P.
GENIE. EN I THINK SIX AND SIX
POINT SEVEN BILLION FOR S. C.
S. C. D. G. ANY M. WAY PAIRS
CAN BE PAYING FOR THESE COSTS
FOR. YEARS OF COURSE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO PREVENT MORE FIRES
BUT WHAT ARE WE DOING WHAT ARE
YOU DOING TO MAKE SURE THIS
MONEY IS BEING. PUT TO GOOD USE.
WELL SENATOR IS. MAKING SURE
THAT THE UTILITIES ARE PUTTING
THAT THE RESOURCES THE BUDGET
IF YOU WILL. THAT IS GIVEN TO
THEM AND PAID FOR THEIR
CUSTOMERS THAT AS PART OF OUR
GENERAL RATE CASE PROCESS. AND
THAT PROCESS IS. A HUGE DEEP
DIVE INTO THEIR OPERATIONS
EVERY ASPECT OF THEIR
OPERATIONS INCLUDING. THEIR
EXECUTIVE PAY OF COURSE- IN IN
THE EDISON G. R. C. WE JUST
HAD- WE LOOKED VERY CLOSELY FOR
EXAMPLE AND HOW TO DEFINE AN
OFFICER OF THE COMPANY. AND NOT
BY TITLE MEANING VICE PRESIDENT
BUT REALLY THEIR ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND WE LOOK
AT THEIR FISHING SEASON THEY'RE
AFFECTING US- BOTH IN IN HOW
THEY HAVE SPENT FUNDS IN THE
PAST BUT THEY HAVE TO TESTIFY
IN PUBLIC TO HAVE THERE ARE
GOING. TO IMPLEMENT THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THAT
THEY'RE ASKING CUSTOMERS TO PAY
FOR. AND IT IS IN THIS PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND ON THE WRITTEN.
TESTIMONY OF THE UNTIL THESE AS
WELL AS THE PARTIES THAT ARE
PART OF OUR PROCESSES CENTERS
IN THE PARTIES ARE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT- TO OUR PROCESS- THE
MANY OF THEM SAID JUST TURN AND
OTHERS I'M EXTREMELY CAREFUL
DILIGENT THEY HAVE ECONOMISTS
ON THEIR STATUS. THEY HELP US
UNDERSTAND AND HOLD OURSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE TO MAKING SURE AND
ENSURING THAT- BEFORE WE VOTE
ON A GENERAL RATE CASE THAT
APPROVES THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS
THAT YOU JUST SPOKE UP. THAT IS
DONE TO LITERALLY ALMOST A
PENNY IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
SPEND THAT MONEY ON THAT CAN
THAT CUSTOMERS- THE RATE PAYERS
MONEY. THAT IS BEING DONE IS
PRUDENTLY AND- EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
PROCESS THAT WE GO THROUGH AND
HAVING JUST COMPLETED THE
ADDISON G. R. C. I CAN ATTEST
TO THE DETAILS THAT MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS COMMISSIONER
SHARON NOT TO US PRECEDING IT
WAS ASSIGNED- AND I WAS
SURVEYING THE SCENE PARTNER
THEY DO DILIGENCE IS DONE BY
STAFF. OUTSIDE CONSULTANTS AND
OF COURSE VERY. IMPORTANT THE
PARTIES TO THE PROCEEDINGS OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT
SENATOR BRADLEY THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK THE PRESIDENT FOR
OVERVIEW OF AN ANNUAL REPORT
BUT WAS SOMETHING GLARING
MISSING FOR ME AND THAT WAS
NOTHING AS IT RELATES TO
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY GENERAL OR
ONE FIFTY SIX PRESLEY IN LIGHT
OF PIECE OF LEGISLATION I
AUTHORED TWO YEARS AGO
REQUIRING THE SHE SHE H. TO-
PROVIDE A AND A REPORT ON THIS
IS THEIR DIVERSE SPENDING AND
HE'S JUST RECEIVED THAT REPORT
AND I. HAVE TO SAY IT WAS
DISAPPOINTING AT THE VERY LEAST
QUOTE TRULY MORE INSULTING-
LOOKING AT THE REPORT- JUST
LOOKING AT THE CCA AND MY
DISTRICT. JUST LOOKING AT-
DISTANT NON ENERGY PROCUREMENT
IT WAS LESS THAN 1% AND I HAVE
MET WITH THE CCA'S AND I'VE
BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOUT MY
CONCERNS OF NOT LIVING UP TO
ANY RESPONSIBILITIES AS IT
RELATES TO- HIRING THE
DIVERSITY AND AGAIN ENGINE
ORDER ONE FIFTY SIX THAT'S BEEN
IN PLACE FOR. OVER THIRTY YEARS
TO THE LAKE WHEN MORE AND THEN
AGAIN THE LEGISLATIONI
INTRODUCED TWO YEARS AGO. I'M
JUST CURIOUS- PRESIDENT
BACHELOR WELL WHAT IS THE P. C.
P. C. GOING TO RESPOND TO THIS
DISMAL REPORT AS A RELATION
CCA'S. AND PUSHED HIM TO
IMPROVE AND TRULY AND- EMBRACE
DIVERSITY NOT ONLY IN HIGHER
BUT IN SPENDING AS WELL
BRADFORD THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING UP GEO ONE FIFTY SIX
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US
AND PERSONALLY TO ME- I HAD TO
SUMMARIZE CREDIT QUICKLY. IN
TERMS OF TIME. AND I AM SORRY
THAT I DID NOT SPEAK TO ONE
FIFTY SIX WE WILL HAPPY HAVING
AS WE DO ANNUALLY A REPORT OUT
ON BOND IN THE EARLY FALL BUT
WE BRING THE PARTIES TO GO. TO
IT SHOULD BE FOR US AND THE
PUBLIC TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
PROGRAMS BOTH PAST AND FUTURE-
GENERALLY SPEAKING THIS YEAR
EVEN WITH THE PANDEMIC- MANY OF
THE GOALS THAT ARE ESTABLISHED-
BY US AND IN ONE FIFTY SIX
CALLED FOR AND THANK YOU TO
RECOGNIZE THE GREAT WONDERFUL.
SHOT LESSER WHEN MORE BUT I
WILL TAKE IT TO HEART WHAT YOU
JUST SAID ABOUT THE CCAC AND-
OUR OFFICE THAT OVERSEES JIO
ONE GB SIX ACTIVITIES WILL ON
AND WILL REPORT BACK TO YOUR
OFFICE AS TO WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO IN ADVANCE OF THE
ENSEMBLE WHERE WE CAN ALSO
BRING THEM INTO CONFLICT AND
TALK TO THEM ABOUT THEIR- FOR
HARMON'S IN MEETING THE GOALS
WE'VE ESTABLISHED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AGAIN I WANNA THANK
THE PRESIDENT- FOR SHAPING THE
LEGISLATURE INFORMED AND FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S ANNUAL
UPDATE TO THE LEGISLATURE. AND
I JUST WANNA SAY I HOPE YOU'LL-
FEEL FREE TO TAKE THE REST OF
THE DAY OFF BUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL- MOVE ON ON OUR
AGENDA NOW AND WE WILL ANNOUNCE
TO THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
AND WILL WALK WELCOME ACT
ACTING DIRECTOR YEP KICKING
GREW UP K. I'M SORRY KIKU GO
OUR WITH THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A
PRESENTATION MMHM FOR THE
PUBLIC IT IS AVAILABLE ON THE
SENATE ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IF YOU WANT TO VIEW
THE- PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICES-
PRESENTATION- AND WE'LL ALSO-
WILL IT BE- WILL BE AVAILABLE
ON SCREEN HERE FOR THE MEMBERS
PRESENTATION NO OKAY I HINK
THE MEMBERS HAVE A COPY MEMBERS
HAVE A COPY- SO- DIRECTOR- IF
K. CAN GROW WELCOME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN PLACE- AND
YET THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
WELCOMING TO ME TODAY AND GAVE
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY
NAME IS AMY YEP HE COULD GO ON
AND I'M ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE WITH
ME HERE TODAY- LINDA SERIZAWA
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR ENERGY.
RICHARD BRUSH FIRE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE WATER BRANCH
ANNEMARIE AT JOHNSON PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE COMMUNICATIONS
POLICY BRANCH AND CHIEF COUNSEL
DARON FARRAR. ADDED THAT AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION WE'RE NOT
IN THE SAME ROOM BUT I WILL
TURN TO THEM IS NEEDED TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE ON MAY TENTH I WAS
ASKED BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
TO TEMPORARILY LEAVE THE OFFICE
UNTIL A PERMANENT DIRECTOR IS
APPOINTED. I WAS HONORED TO
TAKE ON THIS ASSIGNMENT AS I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
FIRST HAND THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE IS WORKING
ACTIVITY OVER THE PAST TWENTY
PLUS YEARS. AS AN ATTORNEY IN
THE COMMISSION'S LEGAL DIVISION
AND MINISTRY OF LAW JUDGE AND
COMMISSIONER PFIZER. I CAN TELL
YOU THERE IS NOTHING MORE
REWARDING THAN BEING TASKED TO
RUN AN ORGANIZATION THAT
PROVIDES A STRONG VOICE FOR
UTILITY CUSTOMERS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE DURING THESE
UNSETTLING TIMES GETTING IMPACT
OF THE COPA CAN DAMAGE
WILDFIRES IN PUBLIC POWER SHUT
OFFS ON THE PROVISION OF
ESSENTIAL UTILITY SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIANS. I'M HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT DESPITE THESE
CHALLENGES THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE SUCCESSFULLY
CONTINUE TO HELP CALIFORNIA
ADVANCE IN SCHOOLS TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND SAFETY.
SINCE MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
SAFELY MET OUR WORKLOAD AND
OPERATIONAL NEEDS BOTH
VIRTUALLY AND BY PHONE AND IN
OTHER. WAYS. IN OTHER WAYS OUR
ADVOCACY CAN TO HELP ENSURE
THAT NO ONE IS LEFT BEHIND AND
THAT EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF
THEIR ZIP CODE HAS ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE STATE. AND FROM
LIABLE ENERGY WATER
COMMUNICATIONS UTILITY SERVICES
YOU HAVE COPIES OF OUR ANNUAL
REPORT IN MY SLIDE DECK BEFORE
YOU AND IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I'LL DRESS SOME OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS IN THESE DOCUMENTS
WHICH YOU CAN REVIEW AT YOUR
LEISURE BEFORE I BEGIN I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST MAKE THE FOLLOWING
STATEMENT. OF MY TESTIMONY MAY
ADDRESS ISSUES ENERGETIC A TORY
IN OR MAKING PROCEEDINGS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY PENDING BEFORE
THE P. YOU SEE WHERE THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE IS A PARTY.
THEREFORE IN ACCORDANCE WITH
COMMISSION WILL EIGHT POINT
THREE C. THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE WILL FILE A NOTICE OF
COMMUNICATION IN THE
APPLICABLES PROCEEDINGS. IF WE
BECOME AWARE OF ANYCOMMISSION
DECISION MAKERS LISTENING INTO
THIS PART OF THE HEARING OUR
MISSION IS TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
LOWEST POSSIBLE UTILITY RATES
FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
CONSISTENT WITH SAFETY
RELIABILITY IN THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. TO ACHIEVE
THIS MISSION MY TOP PRIORITIES
ARE TO ONE INCH SURE WE KNOW
HOW THE COST ANYONE PROPOSED
UTILITY PROGRAM. OR PROJECT
MIGHT IMPACT CUSTOMERS MONTHLY
BILLS. TO ADVOCATE THAT THE
UTILITIES BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
WHEN THEY FAIL TO MANAGE THEIR
SYSTEMS SAFELY AND RELIABLY AND
THREE HELP ADVANCE THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS LAST YEAR
WE PARTICIPATED IN A HUNDRED
NINETY SIX PROCEEDINGS FILED
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
PLEADINGS THAT THE CPUC AND
SUCCESSFULLY INTERACTING WITH
THE PUBLIC AND OTHERS OVER A
THOUSAND TIMES I AM PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT WE SAVE
CALIFORNIANS MORE THAN THREE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS AND
LOWER UTILITY RAP MUSIC AND IF
WE DID THREE INCREASES. LOOK AT
IT ANOTHER WAY FOR EVERY DOLLAR
RATE HERE'S INVEST IN OUR
ORGANIZATION THEY RECEIVED OVER
SEVENTY SEVEN DOLLARS OR TO
HER. AND THIS DOES NOT EVEN
pMONETARY BENEFITS RECEIVED FROM
RATEPAYERS INTERACTION WITH OUR
ADVOCACY OUR ADVOCACY EFFORTS
TO ACHIEVE THE BEST VALUE FOR
CONSUMERS HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THIS PAST YEAR.
AS THE COMMISSION AND THE STATE
AS A WHOLE ADDRESS THE NEED TO
MAINTAIN AND PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS IN THE
FACE OF SHELTER PLACE MANDATES.
WILDFIRES AND INCREASING
DROUGHT CONDITIONS THROUGHOUT
THE WEST. SIDE'S RUN FIVE
THROUGH EIGHT OF MY SLIDE DECK
ADDRESS OUR ADVOCACY EFFORTS IN
MEETING EACH OF OUR POLICY
GOALS. AND I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THEM NOW AS
YOU KNOW ONE OF OUR CORE
FUNCTIONS IS ADVOCATING IN
GENERAL RATE CASES FOR G. R. C.
LAST YEAR WE PARTICIPATED IN
EIGHT YEAR C. AND MOST OF THE
THREE POINT THREE BILLION IN
SAVINGS THAT I JUST MENTIONED
THIS IS A RESULT OF OUR
ADVOCACY IN THOSE PROCEEDINGS
WE ARE TYPICALLY THE ONLY PARTY
TO CONDUCT A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF THE PHILIPPINES G. R.
C. APPLICATION WHICH CAN RUN
THOUSANDS OF PAGES LONG. AND IN
SOME G. R. C.'S INVOLVING SMALL
WATER ENERGY AND COMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES. WE ARE THE ONLY
PARTY EVALUATING THOSE
PROPOSALS WE ALSO HELP
COMMISSION DECISION MAKERS MAKE
MORE WELL INFORMED DECISIONS
ARE COMPLICATED AND DIVISIVE
MATTERS BEFORE THEM THEIR
POLICY PROCEEDINGS BY PROVIDING
THEM WITH OUR FACT BASED
ANALYSES AND RECOMMENDATIONS
AND SOME OF OUR EFFORTS DURING
TWENTY TWO ARE. URGING DEBT
FORGIVENESS TO ALL ENERGY
CUSTOMERS WHO RISKED HAVING
THEIR ELECTRIC SERVICE
DISCONNECTED DUE TO NON PAYMENT
DURING THE PANDEMIC. SUPPORTING
THE LIMITED USE OF TEMPORARY
GENERATORS WHILE URGING A RAPID
MOVED INTO RESOURCES FROM MY
GRANDPARENTS AND PRIORITIZING
MY CORPORATE INCENTIVES TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON FOR COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
SUBJECT TO J. D. ENERGY IS
THAT. SUBJECT TO DE ENERGIZE
NATION SUPPORTING INCREMENTAL
ARI RESOURCES FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SUMMER RELIABILITY MEANS.
REQUIRING WIRELESS PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE AT LEAST SEVENTY TWO
HOURS TO BACK UP POWER TO KEEP
CUSTOMERS IN HIGH FIRE THREAT
AREAS CONNECTED DURING POWER
OUTAGES RECOMMENDING THAT
WIRELINE BROADBAND BE INCLUDED
IN THE UNIVERSAL LIFELINE
TELEPHONE SERVICE PROGRAM. AND
RECOMMENDING THAT THE WATER
REVENUE ADJUSTMENT MECHANISM
SURCHARGES VIA LEMONADE THAT'S
REDUCING CUSTOMER BILLS BY
10220% I HOPE THIS VERY BRIEF
PRESENTATION SHOWS THAT DESPITE
THE CHALLENGES OF THE PAST YEAR
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATED ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS
AND AS THE ST LOUIS OPENS WILL
CONTINUE TO MEET OUR WORKLOAD
AND OPERATIONAL NEEDS
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
RETURN TO WORK POLICY WITH THIS
I'D LIKE TO CONCLUDE AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY. ON THE LAST
SLIDE SLIDE TEN YOU'LL FIND MY
CONTACT INFORMATION IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR IF YOU WANT TO
DISCUSS ANY MATTERS FURTHER.
AND AT THIS POINT AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION OF COURSE WE
ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK
ON BEHALF OF REPAIRS I DID HAVE
ONE QUESTION I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU A THE- HAVE YOU. I MEAN YOU
HAVE YOU THOUGHT OF A DO YOU
HAVE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR
US HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE WHAT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO- HAVE A FOR
US AS LEGISLATORS ON ANYTHING
IN PARTICULAR. WELL AT THIS
POINT NO WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
IN PARTICULAR WE DO APPRECIATE.
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO MEET WITH
US AND- TO SPEAK WITH US ON
VARIOUS ISSUES OF IMPORTANCE TO
GET TO THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE- I KNOW AT THIS POINT I
HAVEN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET ANY OF YOU A ONE ON ONE
AND I DO HOPE TO DO THAT. IN
THE NEAR FUTURE YEAH GIVEN THE-
THESE- INTERESTING IN A
REMARKABLE TIMES WE APPRECIATE.
YOU WANTING TO MAKE WITH US AND
WE WOULD LOVE. TO MEET WITH YOU
SOMETIME SOON AS SOON AS THINGS
BEGIN TO OPEN UP AGAIN BUT
APPRECIATE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
COMING- WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
CALENDAR TODAY ON OUR AGENDA WE
HAVE OUR FINAL ITEM WHICH IS. A
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL NOT MOVE
ITS PUBLIC COMMENT FOR EVERYONE
LISTENING TO THE CHILDREN DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING LATER
HEARINGS AND TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW-
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES
WILL INSTITUTE TIME WHAT. TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY INTO EACH
PERSON WISHING TO SPEAK I MAY
SPEAK FOR A TOTAL OF ONE
MINUTE. AS A REMINDER OF THE
TOLL OF THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
ADMIN MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
HEARING ROOMS. HERE IN THE
GALLERY AND- IN ROOM- WHAT IS
HERE ONE TWELVE ISN'T A. TWENTY
FORTY I'M SORRY THROUGH TWENTY
FORTY. AND IF YOU ARE ALREADY
THERE YOU KNOW THAT- BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL SYSTEM. DID
SISI DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW WOULD BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IT WILL BE- THE
PARTICIPATION NUMBERS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX.
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT SO WILL
WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY HERE IN THE
GALLERY IF WE CAN QUEUE ANYBODY
ROOM WITH TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY
THERE NOBODY SEEMS TO BE
PRESENT DO WE HAVE. ANYBODY ON
THE LINE YOU'LL HAVE ONE MINUTE
TO MAKE ANY COMMENT YOU LIKE
AND IF YOU. WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT LONGER THAN A MINUTE WE
ALSO INVITE YOU TO SEND OUR
OFFICE AN EMAIL LETTER OR ANY
KIND OF COMMUNICATION WILL
DEFINITELY FORWARD THAT TO
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
FOR YOUR BENEFIT- MODERATOR CAN
YOU KEEP CLUE- QUEUE IN OUR-
QUEUE OF THE PUBLIC ON PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONCE AGAIN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM MINE SEVENTEEN. NINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SEVENTEEN
AM I IN COMMITTEE CAN I BE
HEARD WE'RE HEARING YOU FILL
OUT ALL. EXCELLENT GOOD
AFTERNOON FOR NEARLY THREE
YEARS ABC TEN FIRE POWER MONEY
TEAM HAD BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT
COVERING CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE
CRISIS THE DANGER OF PG&E POWER
LINES AND HOW THE COMPANY AVOID
ACCOUNTABILITY NOW ABC TEN
AWARD WINNING INVESTIGATIVE
SERIES REVEALED HOW CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENT UNDER GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM RESPONDED TO PG&E
DEADLY CRIME BY GIVING THE
COMPANY REWARD AND PROTECTION.
ACCORDING TO BRANDON REDDIT
BEEN WITH ABC TEN HE WANTED TO
SEE ALL COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
C. P. U. C. DURING THAT TIME
WHEN BOTH P. GENIES THE CPSC
PRESS. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR FINE AND THE CPUC REFUSE
TO COOPERATE IN THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION OF THE CAMP FIRE
ACCORDING TO PROSECUTORS UNDER
STATE TRANSPARENCY LAWS BRANDON
RITTMAN REQUESTED COMMUNICATION
FROM THE CBSE PRESIDENT WHO WAS
YOUR GUEST TODAY AND AFTER.
SPEAKING AFTER HE SUFFERED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE CPSC
REJECTED THE REQUEST AND THEN
REFUSED ON THE APPEAL FOR MORE
THAN A YEAR THE CASE IS HEADED
TO THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
FRANKLY I THINK THIS IS A REAL
SLAP IN THE FACE OF
CALIFORNIANS GIVING UP ONE
MINUTE TO SPEAK I AM A
DISPLACED PERSON FROM THE TUBBS
FIRE I HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY
AFFECTED OUTSIDE OF MY FOUR
CHILDREN. BECAUSE I WOKE UP
WITH MY CITY IN FLAMES AND WHAT
DID HE PLAYED FROM CINEMA
COUNTY AND I'M LISTENING TO YOU
AND YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO EXPERTS
THERE FROM THE C. P. U. C.
BLAME CLIMATE CHANGE. CAN WE
HAVE YOUR NAME OUR MONOPOLY YOU
KNOW IS A JOKE YOU ARE I WANT
TO SEND AN E. YOUR DOWN CARA IT
EASIER TO IS THANK VERY MUCH A
PART LOCAL TO THE NEXT PICKER
AND IT TAKE YOUR AT THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE. NINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JOHN
KENNEDY WITH WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA I
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR FOCUS ON
INCREASING ELECTRICAL
RELIABILITY AND RESILIENCY IN
CALIFORNIA OUR COMMUNITY IS A
BORN THE BRUNT OF RECENT
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES UTILITY
P. S. P. S. ADVANTAGE. WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FORUTILITY
UP HERE FOR THEM BUT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT UTILITY
INVESTMENTS TO IMPROVE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEREBY
REDUCE THE SIZE SCOPE FREQUENCY
AND DURATION OF PS CHAOS
ABOUNDS ALL WHILE REDUCING THE
OVERALL RISK OF UTILITY CAUSED
WILDFIRE SHE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TREMENDOUS WORK
CONTINUES HIS GUN OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS IN THE P. S. P. S.
MICRO GRIDS AND COMMUNICATIONS
RESILIENCY RING US. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT MUCH MORE WORK
MUST BE DONE TO ENSURE THE HELP
WE CAN KEEP THE LIGHTS ON KEEP
CRITICAL FACILITIES
INFRASTRUCTURE ONLINE KEEP HER
SAFE RUNNING. ELECTRICITY IN
THE ABILITY TO FIGHT RESPOND TO
WILDFIRES AND OTHER EMERGENCIES
ARE CLOSELY RELATED IN ADDITION
TO HARDENING EXISTING
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE CONTINUED
DEVELOPMENT OF MICROGRID AND
ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEMS
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT SUPPORT
CRITICAL FACILITIES IN
COMMUNITIES AT THE GREATEST
RISK OF LOSING POWER. WE KNOW
SOME TYPE OF ENERGY STORAGE
PROJECTS ARE IDEALLY SITUATED
TO ENHANCE FIREFIGHTING
CAPABILITIES IN RURAL AREAS
MANY LOCAL AGENCIES ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS BUT TREMENDOUS
BARRIERS EXIST INCLUDING COSTS
AND DELAYS ASSOCIATED WITH
INTERCONNECTION. PARTICULARLY
AT HIGH SO AND FINALLY WITH THE
PINK SHIFTING US TOWARDS
ELECTRIC VEHICLE COMPLETE
ENERGY RELIABILITY AND
RESILIENCY ARE EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS WHERE THE DISTANCES
INVOLVED OR GREATER AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RECHARGING
ARE FEWER AND FAR BETWEEN.
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE IF YOU SEE THE
KAISER AND OTHERS TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES IN THE NEAR FUTURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE THE-
KIDS THE NEXT PICTURE PLEASE
AND WE ASKED THE SPEAKERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AT THE.
BEGINNING. OF A PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS A
PLEASE GO AHEAD RIGHT YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU HI MY NAME IS
ALLEY THREE OUT AND I WOULD
LIKE TO READ REPORTS OF
COALITION AND REIMAGINE HOW OR
WHEN THE BABY CAME HERE WERE ON
THE COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING TODAY I'M IN
FOR THE VERY INFORMATIVE
PRESENTATION FRIDAY EVEN BEER-
I DID WANT TO SAY THAT WE
REALLY HOPE THAT MICROGRID
DEVELOPMENT CAN BE PRIORITIZED-
IN THIS COMING YEAR BECAUSE IT
HAD NOT BEEN. BARRED SENATOR
STERN PASSED LANDMARK MICROGRID
LEGISLATION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AT THE THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE TO
CREATE MY GREAT GREAT
GRANDPARENTS FOR HELP CUSTOMERS
BE MORE RESILIENT AND I STILL
HAD NOT BEEN DONE AT THE C. P.
U. C. WE APPRECIATE THAT THEY
HAVE TRIED TO CREATE AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR MY
PROGRESS. HOWEVER THE PROJECT
FOR YEARS AWAY FROM BEING BUILT
BY THE GIMMER QUITE OVERSTATED
THE PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE
ON MY CURRENT POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK LASTLY
AS THE FIRST COMMENTER
MENTIONED IT'S REALLY KIND OF
LOOK AT A NEW BUSINESS MODEL
INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT HOW MUCH
MORE TRANSMISSION WE CAN BUILD
WE SHOULD START LOOKING AT MORE
DECENTRALIZED. ENERGY FOR DONE
BETTER BUILT AND SERVED BY
COMMUNITY IF INSTEAD OF THE
UTILITIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR COMING THANK YOU
FOR PARTICIPATING. HOW DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS AND
LADIES AND IF YOU WISH ASK A OR
COMMENT ON TO CALL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT AND. ZERO. OKAY
THERE NO FURTHER COMMENTS I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS TODAY PLEASE. SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE
SUBCOMMITTEE I'M SORRY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE. ON SENATE
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTAMENT IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE AND
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON SENATE
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS HIS KNOWLEDGE-